There are men that die every year to get you crab. How many women
die every year during child? >> You talk about crab fisherman
die every year to get you crab. How many >> to get you
crab?
How many men die every year
to get you crab to get you delicious seafood?
Wait, what? Why did she just say that? What the is she talking
about? Dude, what? Women have 85% of consumer spending. Women
spend money all the time. You spend money on hair dye. You spend
money on Botox. You spend money on
You spend money all of the time.
Very sad. Okay, headliners were things fired up. All right, we're
ready to go to the headline debate. It's Pearl versus Anakasparian.
Maybe they've worked out the kinks. Okay, maybe they'll have
working mics potentially. Could you imagine working mics for
this event? Could you imagine how great this would be >> if
they had working microphones? >> I'm I'm just thinking
about it it possibly coming true. >> The main event is
here. I'm Sam Tripley. I am blessed to be here at the analyst
table. To your left is Tyler Turner and to the right the man
who's just lighting up the internet right now, Gavin. Guinness.
Yes. >> I'm Gavin Guinness. >> Yes. Real quick, guys,
I want to give a shout out to all the wonderful people who came
to the live show tonight. Stuck through the whole night. Give
yourselves a round of applause.
>> And we want to give a shout out to the over 20,000
people watching live. We appreciate you and love you. Even you
guys watching the weird logo for an hour. Thank you guys so much.
We love you to pieces. Uh the big event is here again. Anna Kasparian
versus Pearl Davis. We're going to be breaking down feminism.
Has it been good for women? Has it been bad? And I think we got
to go to the expert on that. Gavin McInness, what do you think
about
what feminism has done for women to women by women and what it's
done to men? >> I think both these girls should be at home
in the kitchen making sandwiches. Why are they even here? Why
are they >> That's a good political cooking. And
>> so to be fair, Pearl also wonders that. Pearl also wants
that. Uh, that is the qu a question for the ages. Why can Pearl
not find a husband?
Far spicier question. Why can Pearl not find a white husband?
But we won't go there. We'll just leave it on. Why can't Pearl
find a husband? >> Cleaning right now. They shouldn't be
allowed the stage. >> All right. Well, let's hear the counterpoint
from the ladies. Okay. Kyla, thoughts on women should be making
>> if they're good at them. But men should make the sandwiches
too if they're good at them. >> Now, now let's let's be
honest. >> So, actually, you see, it's actually the ancient
Greeks believed that sandwich making was the providence of men.
Actually, Spartan warriors all made sandwiches. In fact, >> do
you think feminism has been good for your species?
>> You think it's been good for women?
>> Can any thoughts on why
you think it's been good for women?
Yeah, it is rough. It is rough being up there, isn't it?
>> Any thoughts on why you think they've been good why
it's been good for women? >> I think that it is both uh
inevitable >> on why you think they've been good why it's
been good for women. I think that it is both uh inevitable within
a society and a moral good. Um yeah. >> Now when we find
out that uh almost 60% of women uh say they have mental
do you do you think that has anything to do with feminism and
this kind of demonic energy that we all know feminism is right?
Demonic energy. Uh, do you think it has anything to do with them
kind of going against their own wiring, basic instincts? >> I
just think women are more honest about what their mental status
is at. >> Oh, so you're saying men just eat it? >> Yeah,
they eat it more. >> That's probably why we're better.
You know what I'm saying? >> You say that, but you guys
are killing yourselves more. You're addicted more. You're in
you're in jail more. So, I don't know. This >> We're out
there building society. You get arrested for that.
>> You're you're making moves. You're you're changing the
world. Yeah.
We out here making moves. Okay. Sometimes you just choke a [__]
out cuz she cheated on you. Okay. We out here making moves. >> Going
to be some collateral damage where you end up in jail >> by
doing like murdering and people. >> No [__]
getting arrested for
>> feminism has turned women into [__] and
alcoholics and they don't like or booze. So, it's been a >> Okay,
I he says that as both us who I listen, I can say for the people
on this panel, I've only seen one person here shove a dick up
their own ass, okay, on camera on the internet for money. There's
only one person I've seen do that. Shockingly,
not the person who looks like they possibly own an Only Fats,
okay? I'm just saying. I'm just
>> he is he is the drunk he is the alcoholic like worker
on this panel by by all measures. Okay. Moms, >> what's
a political correct term we could use for
>> uh I don't even I I don't know. >> Women Women
living their best lives. >> I have no idea what the PC
term for >> What about liid? >> I have no idea. I
don't even know where to start. >> Maybe libidus.
>> Okay.
Is libidious.
>> What would you say? >> Lebidius. Sorry. I flung
>> Oh, Sam's drunk too. Cool. >> Listen. Um, do you
think that's been good? The promiscuous society culture that
we're in? >> Um, yes and no. Right. Like in in many ways
it's allowed people to like explore relationships long before
they have to commit to like marriage and so it's allowed for
like a decline in divorce over time. However, at the same time
it's also led to like risky. The issue is that
here's my argument for feminism. Feminism is about choice. It's
about agency. Agency is like one of the most fundamental things
that are inherent to the American project. And the issue is that
people can choose the wrong thing that you don't like. >> Their
microphones are literally just not set up very well. Riyle, I
do think somebody is trying to like control which microphone
is picking up sound at any given time. And I think there's like
a delay and so I do think sometimes you hear like the mic pick
up without them moving very much. I think somebody's like literally
trying to control the level so they're not reverbing off of each
other or something. I don't know. >> And that doesn't mean
to rob them of agency. Of agency. Yeah. But they also get to
choose good things. >> Choose the wrong thing. Choose feminism.
By the way, option is being a >> You married your high
school sweetheart. You're very traditional. >> Not my high
school sweetheart
to a camp who are in trouble with the law. >> She married
her first love. >> So that actually speaks. I've lived
all of the traditional worldview that you guys love and purport
for. And I'm telling you that it isn't just everything. It isn't
what is. >> So you hate your husband?
>> She loves her husband. >> I love my husband. So
you're madly. So >> but the issue is that if you look for
>> I do think Gavin might have her here a little bit. >> People
who marry like one of their first relationships for example orgasm
rates amongst religious women is at like an alltime low. Yep.
Women don't have good when they get married early.
>> I got to ask I got to ask this. Should we care that
women are having orgasm when they're not paying for anything
>> they are paying? I think they're Wait
there. You could get really funny with this. Wait, is that like
causal? Wait, is that causal? Like if you don't have very much
that you just get married to somebody early, you like don't orgasm.
Is that causal and then it's okay. So your husband can't make
you orgasm or it's not causal and it's not really related. It's
just like it's probably just overall like it's probably the the
prudish worldview of people who do get married early, right?
It's not it's not the fact that they got married or it's not
the fact that they live a traditional life. It's just the shaming
of that you could get rid of that while still living a mostly
traditional life. You just embrace marriage, which tons of Christians
do. They pay significant amount of taxes. U that's why they've
entered the workforce. It's why they have so much political power.
It's important. Um should they have good? Yeah, of course. If
you love your partner, right? Like this is one of the issues
I hate with the gender paradigm is it creates this like this
tit fortat where if they get anything good then we get nothing
good. And it's like that what I want in relationship is for both
both sides of the relationship to be >> It creates this
for if you love your partner, right? Like this is one of the
issues I hate with the gender paradigm is it creates this like
>> she hates the gender paradigm that creates a tit fortat.
Does this even so it sets up a theoretical game where the strategy
tit fortat is employed >> this tit fortat where if they
get anything good then we get nothing good and it's like that
what I want >> um that's not what tit fortat means. A zero
sum game could be appropriate there, right? As in things that
we get, they lose, right? But tit for tat is not appropriate
here. You are using that because you've heard people use that
word and you are just copying it without understanding it. >> In
relationship is for both both sides of the relationship to be
happy and and >> You feel that in modern day society, women
both want the perks of traditional relationships and >> it's
so annoying. It's so I get I just like I actually get so annoyed.
I get so annoyed when people do this. >> The perks of modern
day relationships. >> Some do. Yeah, for sure. Some do.
But the issue is that not all do. >> Uh no, but the issue
is not all do, right? But I don't want that. In many ways, while
I have a very traditional relationship, I also am the bread winner,
right? I also um in many ways do most of the career stuff. But
at the same time, if you look at Nick, nobody would look at my
husband and think that he's not masculine, right? He's ripped.
He's attractive. >> Masculine man. >> He's masculine.
he just beat Ben Thorp in an arm wrestle, right? And so we know
we know that even though in many ways I'm defying the traditional
gender roles, I'm also satisfying it. And this is all I want
is for people to make choices. I don't want to tell people how
the relationships must be, I'm going to tell them here's what
generally works for most people, but it might not work for you
because it didn't work for me. >> Okay. And final thoughts
as we got a minute to to the debate. Final thoughts,
>> I just thought of this right now, but I'm like just
like I I thought men should wear leather jackets tonight. I just
thought of this. I don't think women really likes it. Like they
like pleasing their man and they like having a stable relationship
and they know he likes it, but I don't really think they actually
enjoy the act. >> Let me ask. >> You as a woman.
>> He's just going to throw that one out >> Find
that women love sex. >> I think a lot of women really enjoy.
There's a reason why so many women absolutely
discover a >> dude. Somebody show that to Andrew Andrew
Tate. Okay.
Andrew Tate has the Andrew Tate understands this element. Okay,
I heard him talk about this once. Okay, that's that is [__]
only in this one what women desire what women like
that women do desire. Okay, it's literally like critically important
and people who think otherwise just don't >> toy and have
a great time. Good is good for everyone. >> I think women
love because they can just lay down and guy has to do all the
work. Is there any truth to that? >> I would say that that
is not good.
What? Why did Playgirl not exist? Why did Play Girl sells zero
copies? Cuz women are not really horny. >> Well, because
Play Girls for
>> That's not how they get off.
Go to a bookstore and go to the erotica section. Look at how
much any of this [__] there appeals to you. >> Gay
men. That's >> who doesn't know this? How do you How do
you be this disconnected from like the opposing gender? How do
you just know nothing about the opposing gender at all? I don't
I don't get it.
I mean, who's consuming erotica?
>> Women. What? No. Women.
>> Why are women reading a novel right now that talks about
how uh women are are
uh
>> I don't even know what we're >> That was the number
one book on the New York Times for women. At one point,
>> women are m
>> You need what Gen Xers need. Okay, Gen Xers need to
do this for the internet. literally
ban, deplatform all Gen Xers who started drinking before 30 because
their brains are the perfect advertisement for why you should
never have alcohol in your life. Okay? All of these guys who
were like funny and partying in their 20s and 30s, now that they're
like 40 and 50, they are so embarrassing all the time. Leave.
Boo.
Throw tomatoes at these losers. Get get ones who started drinking,
who got popular or something when they were 30, okay? Cuz all
the guys who were like popular in their 20s, like in in media
in some way, their brains are totally fried. It's so embarrassing
to watch. >> Ask the important questions here at Word War
Debate. Let's send it down to the best LOOKING MAN I KNOW, BEN
SWAN.
>> They need to figure out whatever whatever the NFL does
to pipe in crowd noise, okay? Whatever these stadium owners do,
they need to figure that [__] out of this. Oh my
god, >> it's rough.
>> Oh, here we go. Oh. >> Oh, and then they in the
middle of it just bring Anakas Barian out.
dude. There's no way
between Ben and Grace Thorp. Okay.
And the guy in the wheelchair. Do they have more homeless people
than like employed people in the audience?
>> Dude, Red Red Bar will light this event up like badly.
He will. You red bar will almost certainly cover this event,
right? Just because of Sam Cholley being there. Pick me versus
Republican Light. I don't know how Republican Light Anakasparian
is. Can Anakas Casparian is just kind of like uniquely too charitable
to people who are going to
She's like the uh the sheep who's voting wolf right now. Okay,
>> let's get the energy up. Yeah, love it. >> I'm
very happy to be here. >> All right, she says scraping
a little bit. So, let's get Pearl in here. Come on, Pearl.
Here she comes.
I need the Britney. Can I get the Britney Venty commentary on
the fit? Can we see the Britney Venty commentary on the fit?
What's the fit like? Britney, what about Lav? Is Lav around?
Lav, can we get a comment on the fit here? I'd say I will give
Pearl this. Okay. The makeup is way better than it's been before.
She actually looks way better than I expected. The makeup is
better. The hair might even work. I don't know about the fit.
I don't know about this like Sunday school teacher ass fit that
she's pulling. But
I will say Okay, hold on. Pirate act next. Pearl is not graceful.
Okay,
there's there's no amount Jesus Christ.
That's a huge
This guy's getting towered over. Holy sh Jesus. Pearl at scale
is not cool. What the [__]
>> I was about to say she's not graceful. Seeing her emotion
really doesn't do her any any favors. But holy, she's asking
question. If you're going to change somebody's mind,
>> why doesn't Pearl simply just simply eat Anakasparian?
Why is Pearl not just eating Anakaspar? I don't get it. By the
way, this is how
I Dude, I hate to say it. I'm going to say something kind of
transphobic. This is how I knew that the people I knew Brian
Woo was trans because I was on the internet like vaguely at some
point at the tail end of Gamergate. So, like I knew that because
it was a big thing back then. But the thing that always let me
know for sure was no matter how
how much you lack grace, no matter how uncoordinated you are,
if you are a woman who is like over 6'2, you automatically get
a university scholarship. And Briana Woo didn't. Right? If you're
a woman over 6'2, you auto get a scholarship because literally
just your ability to stand high this high on in volleyball or
basketball or whatever, you automatically get a scholarship.
Pearl had a free ride to school. Pearl was like a a university
volleyball player, I believe, right?
And Brianna Woo had a whole thing where her parents paid for
her to go to school or whatever. So, like literally just not
having a scholarship, you you I automatically know that you Listen,
you weren't eligible.
>> I'm first. >> I thought so. Anna, take it away.
We got 5 minutes
>> in a May 2024.
>> Yeah, that's that's basically like Yeah. 6'4 guys, you
don't automatically get a scholarship in college. 6'4 6'4 women
do. Like automatic. >> Appearance on Tim P's Culture War
podcast. My opponent Pearl Davis declared that women aren't really
doing much. we're not having kids. We're not really contributing
to the economy when you look at output.
In fact, she uses this ridiculous assertion to argue that women
should not have the right to vote. While it's true the birth
rate has declined, and we'll revisit that in a bit, women account
for 47%
of the American workforce. The Council of Economic Adviserss
found that women have contributed a substantial portion of the
US economic growth since 1970,
which wouldn't have been made possible without the feminist movement.
By 2017, women were responsible for nearly 40% of total gross
domestic product, amounting to a whopping 7.6 trillion. Of course,
that figure doesn't include the trillions of dollars in unpaid
labor women do every year tending to the household, raising children,
and caring for ailing parents.
And when it comes to certain sectors of our economy, women are
a dominant and indispensible force like in the healthcare industry
where they make up
Imagine wages. If we lost 50% of the workforce, they would get
so high.
Okay?
Why would the birth rate go up? This is so stupid. People don't
understand economics. There's maybe some argument that you could
lose a lot more people out of the workforce moving forward as
AI or robotics, more specifically robotics by a lot, but AI a
little bit starts to remove the need for human labor. Okay?
But the idea that you just remove women from the workforce and
wages go up, you're so stupid. You have no idea how economics
works. You have no idea about economies of scale. You have no
idea that any productive force in any way just from any person
adds to your economy. Okay? There's like people just think, "Oh,
well, the same companies would be here." No, it would be like
Can I meme? No, cuz Andrew Wilson's made this point seriously
in a debate before. So, nobody can ever meme on it because the
best right-wing debater made this point very seriously in a debate
that I watched and I had to suffer through. So, no, you don't
get to joke about it. >> 80% of workers according to the
Bureau of Labor Statistics. That's 16.4 million women. When it
comes to education, in 1960, women earned less than 35% of all
bachelor's degrees. Today, they earn roughly 58% of all bachelor's
degrees, which Pearl herself benefited from after graduating
from Elmherst University. Women also earn over 60% of master's
degrees. I hope to hear Pearl explain how a more educated and
skilled population somehow translates to cultural decline, especially
as we compete with China in this increasingly multipolar world.
The modern feminist movement also had a major impact on decreasing
domestic violence. And that's according to the US Department
of Justice. Rates of intimate partner violence decreased by more
than 60% from 1994
to 2010. And that's thanks to protective order statutes and funding
for shelters beginning in the 1970s and 80s. Not only did the
twoinome household become more financially resilient, especially
during economic downturns, women gained the ability to leave
abusive relationships, an outcome correlated with improved child
health and educational attainment.
A culture that protects people from violence is not one that's
indicative of cultural decline. Pearl herself. >> H do
you think what do you think the odds are that Pearl's going to
say endure during this? Uh I feel like Anakasparian saw the clip.
Okay, she's going to try to force it down that way.
>> Has benefited greatly from the feminist movement thanks
to Title 9 in 1972 signed by >> Sorry, I was doing something
real. >> Discrimination in any school program or activity
that receives federal funding is prohibited. Pearl herself had
a rather impressive record playing for Elmherst University's
volleyball team, having earned all conference honors as a senior.
She later pursued professional volleyball in London.
She could have stayed in the United States and served in her
role as a traditional woman,
but she now now hold on. Can I ask if Pearl goes, "Do you guys
think Pearl is being legitimate or do you trust her opinion?"
When she goes, "Yeah, I I like live the egalitarian lifestyle
and like I'm I'm the best example of this." I think traditional
is better. Is that worth is that worth anything? Is that like
special in some way? Okay. >> Cuz obviously no, right?
Obviously no. And she could have been the traditional chasteed
woman living out her dream of everything women were supposed
to do before feminism,
but she is neither traditional nor chasteed by her own admission.
While feminists would have no problem with her personal choices,
she has made a career bashing women for theirs. Critics often
argue that modern feminism has weakened families and resulted
in a lower birth rate. Hannah, imagine if Anaka Kasparian just
ripped the last like 60 seconds of her opener just from the Britney
Venty video. Started Pearl's style, started Pearl in every way
possible. Why? Why couldn't we get that? >> They tend to
dismiss empirical evidence demonstrating the insidious impact
of the internet, social media, on modern relationships. They
also brush economic instability under the rug despite young people
citing their personal finances as the main reason why they're
holding off on marriage in the first place. In lie of discussing
those factors, Pearl spends much of her time discouraging men
from getting married in the first place. During her debate with
Trent Hol
that men are better off shacking up without ever getting married.
>> Her reasoning, women are too fat and STD
>> 25%. That's a lot. >> You did say that. She didn't
stop to
>> Let's Let's just understand that Pearl was born this
way. And by I don't mean mentally. I mean she was born, you know,
at 13 years old. She was tall enough to bang her head on the
top of door frames, okay? And that has led to brain damage, CTE,
like you wouldn't believe, okay? Pearl never had a shot in this
world. And we all need to be cognizant of that and respectful.
>> Think about how they contracted the STDs in the first
place. Data from the National Library of Medicine show that modern
men are just as promiscuous as modern women. >> Men and
women are in bad shape. And in the United States, we can discuss
why, but feminism is not the reason. >> There you go. Thank
you. Nice job. Okay, Pearl, we got 5 minutes. You're going to
be on the clock and let's go. >> Most debaters and commentators
are elitists who >> can we get Dude, can we get Pearl's
mic moved up like 8 in, please? Can we get Somebody needs to
go adjust this mic? It needs to go up 8 in. I cannot hear Pearl.
She's too far away from the mic. Somebody help. >> Average
Americans from their ivory towers, what to think and how to feel.
My answer to this question not only comes from covering current
events and researching the facts, data, and statistics, but also
in my professional experience interviewing over a thousand people
in America and Western nations. Feminism has given women power
and power corrupts. And that's what's happening. Feminism is
robbing men of their disposable income and their prime earning
years. Feminism feminism has empowered women. It has empowered
women to be promiscuous. Feminists say that they fought for women
to not sub subject themselves to the approval of men. Why then
are five to 10% of women between the ages of 18 to 25 on >> Oh,
don't do the only fans. Don't do the >> only prostitution
sites. >> It's just not true. It's just not true. >> There
are more online prostitutes in America than female Walmart employees.
>> We we literally went through this and pro and showed
like how she got these numbers from somewhere and they're like
totally made up. They're totally
>> One of three women will catch an STD at some point in
their lifetime. 90%
>> Pop Shake, you think 10% of women are on Only Fans?
You think you think 10% of women are on Only Fans? Bro, what?
>> Will catch HPV, which is incurable. Feminism has empowered
women to abort an eighth of the world population and a third
of Gen Z. Feminists have been so empowered to commit paternity
fraud. Paternity fraud is unpunished in any state in the USA
or any country in the West. If done correctly, a man will have
to pay for a child he was fooled into believing was his until
that child reaches maturity. In some states, that man will have
will also have to pay for that kid's college. That is slavery
and is forbidden under the 13th Amendment. One-third of paternity
tests are negative by the American Association of Blood Banks.
Feminism has empowered women to rob men. rob men of their time,
their resources, their reputation, their children, and in the
most extreme cases, their lives. They do this through child support,
alimony, false allegations, and paternity fraud. How many people
in this arena have a brother, a father, an uncle, or a friend
who has gone through this meat grinder?
>> Anna has been on the air for 15 years and is
>> she's just like, "Look, the homeless guys agree.
Look, look, the home.
See, look, they agree with me. Hey, the crowd's on my side. How
could I be wrong? The crowd's totally on my side over here. Come
on, man. I should probably get a better time stamp for this,
but it's fine. >> Anna has been on the air for 15 years
and is completely oblivious to these issues. It's a silent genocide
of the lives of millions of men. Standing on the sidelines of
the arena, I have 33-year combat veteran Terrence Pop. He served
through three wars and was almost killed in two. He got married,
had two children, and served in the United States Army. Terrence
Pop was deployed to Iraq in 2004 and as a member of the Airborne
Infantry, he was wounded by a roadside bomb and suffered a TBI
and a stroke from the blast. He was evacuated out of the country
and it took over two years until he had recovered. While he was
recovering, his wife was plotting to divorce him. His wife murdered
his six-year-old Chocolate L out of spite because he >> What
the
dude? This is This is on and that's on all women. Okay, this
evil women when women didn't kill this woman when they didn't
lynch her immediately. It's on this. It's on all of you. Okay,
it's on all of you. >> Filed for divorce first. When he
confronted her, the response he got was, "I told you I did not
want you living
At this point, he was forced to leave the marital home and live
out of his car. The divorce took away his home, his children,
and left him penniless and saddled with a child support payment
he could not afford. Terrence had to pay
over a 12-year period for a divorce that his wife was empowered
by feminists to plan and execute.
>> Wait, only 10? Isn't that He had kids and he paid 10,000
a year.
Isn't that get it off pretty light? Wait, 144,000 over a 12-year
period. That's like really low child support, isn't it? That's
Oh, that's Yeah. 12 12 years. 12 months. That's literally $1,000
a month. No, sorry. Yeah. No. 12 years, 12 months. It's $1,000
a month of child support. Yeah, that's not that high. >> Terrence
went into court to fight. >> 2005, maybe it's a little
higher back >> For 50 years, Terrence was called a murderer
and an assassin in open court and was given 96 hours a month
with his children. 96 hours a month is not a father.
While homeless, he spoke to many other men who would never get
off the streets due to child support or rearages and penalties.
And the
>> he actually was homeless. THERE ACTUALLY ARE THERE actually
are a bunch of homeless people in the crowd. Let's >> child
support. The disparage of losing his children and his home and
his PTSD and constant pain from his wounds, he became while at
his post. In 2008, a former commander of his came to see him
to secretly say his last goodbyes. The next day, Mr. Pop's former
commander put on his dress blues and went to the Holy National
Veteran Cemetery and blew his brains out. Terrence Pop was notified
of the death and was shocked because he was planning to commit
suic.
So in effect, his former commander took the bullet that was meant
for him. Darren Pop decided he would not kill himself and has
spent the last 20 years saving 576
men from with comedy. If you look to the left of the
>> back to word war debates >> stage, Terrence is
holding the dog tags for every life that he has saved. Now, why
am I telling you this? Shout out to Terrence. Yeah.
Now, why am I telling you this? Because men and American veterans
are put in this position because of the empowerment that feminists
like Anna have pushed for. There are millions of men that have
died in this country from the political power that feminism pushes
since 1970. An estimated 1.
She >> just got time.
>> If feminists cared about equality, why aren't they fighting
for equality in divorce and family court as hard as they are
fighting for abortion, working, or becoming sex workers? Thank
you. >> Okay, this this is going to be it's going to be
a heavy one. We're going to go now to the opening interrogation.
>> Literally, the whole thing was just telling that guy's
story. She just told that guy's story about how he was cut in
half by a divorce.
That was not even that bad. >> We have 10 minutes. We have
that on the
>> Yeah, it's fading in right there. Okay. And take it
away. 10 minutes. >> Who's interrogating who? >> Whoever
wants to begin. Aside from the specific anecdote that you shared,
which of course is tragic, can you cite some actual studies that
look at the statistics and back up what you say in regard to
the outcomes of marriage and divorce in America?
>> 41% of cases reported to police in a Midwestern city
were admitted to be false by complaints >> in one Midwest
western city.
>> And which Midwestern city was that? I I don't like this
way of debating
like okay it's it might might be valid. It's the argument you're
making is like like obviously in a city you would probably have
a large enough sample size to say something.
I do think if you listen to that stat I would probably start
doing what Anna's doing anyway cuz 41% of filers of complaintants
said so 41% of people who filed claims said they admitted after
the fact that it was made up. What? That's way too high. That's
That's nuts.
>> You know, you can go from your ivory tower and >> I'm
not in an ivory tower. I'm on this debate stage interrogating
your assertions and you've only provided an
>> Because if you look at the data, which I did, of course,
you'll find that >> Oh, Anna is 5 foot three. Pearl is
like 5 foot six. One, Anna's probably wearing heels. Okay. And
two, Pearl is at least a full head taller, if not more. Pearl
is
are twice as likely to fall into poverty after divorce. Alimony
is paid out in 10% of divorces. According to the Census Bureau,
the average child support >> Oh, Pearl's also wearing heels.
Pearl's wearing like pretty big heels.
Bro, why would you wait? Is she not? Maybe they're boots. They
look like heels for a second. Maybe they're just boots. There's
no way she'd be wearing heels, right? There's no way. >> Is
$441
a month and only 60%
of those payments get paid out. Women do not get child custody
90% of the time as you have asserted before. In fact, 95%
of custody cases are mutually agreed upon outside of the courtroom.
Women get full custody 40% of the time. Men
>> um 6 feet tall. Uh I believe that kind of kind of okay
>> do get full custody 20% of the time and 40% of the time
it's shared custody which I think is the ideal situation assuming
that neither spouse is abusive
>> and uh Pearl excuse me before you respond if you could
um take your microphone out and hold it would be easier to hear
you. >> Okay. Alimony and medical care and >> dude
this is already rough. Is she really just going to read? She's
really just going to read.
Pearl deadlifts 300. That's I don't think that's high that high
for women. Women can deadlift a lot.
Uh
if you ever go to like a powerlifting gym, you'll see a lot of
women who can deadlift 300 lb. I'm 6' tall and I can deadlift
300 lb. I played semi-pro volleyball and had pro contracts offered
to me. I'm stronger than taller than 90% of women. You will not
convince me we can do their jobs. Yeah. Like women women can
have pretty solid like core strength, pretty solid lower body
strength. Okay. They can squat decently. They can deadlift decently.
They just don't have upper body strength. They'll never bench
like men bench, right? Just don't have they they literally don't
have like upper body strength. But lots of women can deadlift.
I I believe I know women who could deadlift like over 500 lb.
Uh yeah, I'm pretty sure >> dental are not covered by that.
So a lot of times it does go above 50%.
>> Again, you can go through the facts, the data, and the
statistics and manipulate them any way that you want. >> It's
not there are 1.6 million. There are 1.6 6 million men in this
country. Men are nine times more likely to commit after a divorce
>> compared to women. What's the number for >> It's
lower. >> Really? What is it? Comparative analysis is real
difficult for you, isn't it? >> Know them personally? Um,
no, I don't know them personally. I just realized how
much I narrowed that down. Never mind. I don't know them. >> Go
ahead, Pearl. >> What's your next question?
You have asserted that men shouldn't get married, that instead
they should shack up. You did say that with Trent Horn, word
for word, you said it makes more sense for them to shack up,
live with a girlfriend instead of getting married. Do you think
the advice that you give to men is the type of advice that will
fulfill their lives? Because I'll tell you one thing, the best
part of my life is my husband. I love my husband. He's my rock.
He's my foundation.
>> And and no, my husband is number one. I love my career.
But you know what my career did? When I met my husband, my career
was already established. He, on the other hand, was couch surfing.
He was in debt and didn't know what he wanted to do with his
life. I married >> And is there anything more masculine,
Anna? You're kind of proving Pearl's point because is there anything
more masculine than marrying a rich bum because you're horny
in your 30s? Okay. There's no more masculine thing than that,
Anna. All right. I defy you to name something.
She married like a professional baseball player, right? like
some hot Dancing with the Stars
dancing odd professional baseball player or some [__]
I'm pretty sure she did that. >> Anyway, you want to know
why? Because I had the economic freedom to marry for love, not
for some Chad to take care of me. How tall is he? >> Oh,
he's 6'1. About your height. >> How many did you give him?
>> None. I don't want
>> Anna. Anna can crack that whip sometimes. God damn,
that was brutal. Let's Let's not do shouting questions from there.
Please allow these two to debate each other. Okay. What's your
>> I mean, you don't really have much to answer, so I don't
know what else to ask you. Do you think you're helping men by
discouraging them from entering fulfilling marriages?
>> What happens to men if they don't pay child support?
>> I mean, what happens? What happens,
>> How many men do you think get arrested? I don't know
what the number is, but the idea that there's like a huge number
of men getting arrested for not doing what they're supposed to
do >> and take care of their children, it's not a huge
issue. What happens to men when they don't really only 60% of
child support get allow her to you got to allow her to interrogate
you not them. You got to stop yelling questions at her. >> You
can minimize men's problems all you want. But I don't think you
understand how privileged of a position you're in. >> In
what way? How am I privileged? >> Men are the ones that
are on the hook for child support. Men are the ones that are
on the hook for alimony. It's easy for you to tell 10 tell men
to just take the risk when if you're not in that >> So
are you asserting that men shouldn't pay child support following
a divorce? Do you believe that women should be financially responsible
100% after feminists wanted to be equal? So I say be equal. If
you guys want equality, 50/50 custody, no child support, no alimony,
no special privileges. >> Alimony is paid out in 10%. >> It
doesn't matter if you're part of the >> Alimony is literally
only ever paid out when one spouse is like totally economically
dependent on the other. And to like live their life, they've
sacrificed. It's literally how it's calculated. Like how much
did they sacrifice to like build the marriage, the marital home?
That's how alimony gets paid out, man. It's like not even confusing.
It's so stupid when they
It's like It's like, yeah, this this person for they they they
decided to forgo a career. They built your home instead. Maybe
now your argument will be, well, they were lazy. It's like I
don't Okay, but you agreed to this. You know how this goes.
This is because what used to happen Okay, what used to happen
when was more agrarian economy. So, you'd have farmers who get
quote unquote married to some woman. They live with them for
50 years. They have 10 kids together. And then they kick the
wife to the curb. They divorce the wife. They don't give them
anything. The wife has no skills, no ability to like earn a living.
They're just totally,
right? That can't be a situation that you end up in. That has
to be a family that you built together, a house that you built
together. You have to be willing to understand that if you want
to get married, if you don't like that, then don't get married.
Don't have a
>> It does matter because you make it seem like it's a
widespread issue when it's
a It's law against men. That's >> how is it if a woman
decided to forgo a career, decided to be a stay-at-home mother
and the marriage doesn't work out. She has no job. She has no
income. So, you think it's unfair to get support from her ex-husband
so she can raise the kids. 60% 60% of kids under five have daycare.
Daycare is an option now. You want it to be men. Do you know
how much day you wanted? You wanted to be men. Here you go. You
know how much
answer? Let her answer. >> A lot of things are expensive,
Anna. I mean, it's men. That's not an answer. >> Women
have 85% of consumer spending. Women spend money all the time.
You spend money on hair dye. You spend money on Botox. You spend
money ON THE >> YO, WHAT THE HOLY,
What the I thought this is a feminist debate. She just said,
"You look like a hag. Ugly [__] Ugly, tall, huge
ass >> 5% of consumer spending. Women spend money all the
time. >> Hold on. I need to go back. >> A lot of
things are expensive. >> We need to go back far enough.
Hold on. That's not an answer. >> Women have 85% of consumer
spending. Women spend money all the time. You spend money on
hair dye. You spend money on Botox. You spend money. >> You
should think about it >> on the
>> I sure am
all of the time. >> did you hear that part? Wait, did you
hear that part?
>> I sure am. >> To be men. Here it is. You're equal
pay for daycare. Equality means that when you have a child or
children, you're both responsible. So, the idea that the woman
should take 100% of the costs on herself without any help from
her husband or ex-husband is ridiculous. How is that fair? >> Well,
how is it fair that he doesn't get 50/50 custody? >> Well,
he first of all,
>> he's Why are you asserting that they >> It's 50%
his DNA. Why can't he have 50%
>> I'm pretty sure that the stats they site, Dude, I Why
do I have to watch
I I like watching this. It's the red pillar stuff. I'm just like
so annoyed. I'm pretty sure the stats they site are from like
all divorces. And when you only look at divorces where par where
the dad seeks custody, you almost always get 50/50 custody. Or
not almost always. Sorry, it's not that. It's not that. It's
not that. Some men do get it's probably way higher than it should
be. But men just don't apply for custody. Like very often men
do not apply for custody of the kids, especially not full custody.
It's um if men seek full custody, I do believe they're far more
likely, the stats are far more favorable in their favor to get
full custody. Sorry. It's Is it usually 50/50? I thought it was
still a split that favored the mom and that custody agreements
generally favored the mom because I think most judges look at
like who has taken who's taken a larger part of raising the kids
and usually that's the wife, right?
Make a way to save clips for streamers such as yourself. What
do you mean? There are lots of ways to save clips. >> Where
has a study? >> Let me answer your question. Even though
I should be interrogating you, I'll answer your question. >> Massive
study out of Massachusetts that looked at 24,000 divorces. In
those 25 divorces, they found that in only 8% of cases did men
ask for custody.
>> Because the average American can't afford divorce fees,
Anna. >> But women afford to raise the children by themselves
without support from the
>> How does that make sense? >> I What did you say?
I didn't hear you. We were both talking. You're complaining about
the costs while simultaneously arguing that a woman should not
get child support in order to
>> when men seek custody they get they win it 90% of the
time. Oh, that's way better than I thought. But that's about
what I would think is like they they seek custody, they're going
to get it some amount of the time. I would imagine in most divorces
that it comes out as like amicable. It's like, hey, this is how
I want we both want child c like child custody to go. That in
like a large share of divorces probably amicable. They just decide
we're going to do something together. We We know what we want
the solution to be. And then where it has to be decided where
both parties are saying the other party shouldn't have anything,
right? Or should have less. Like I would imagine it's pretty
close to 50/50 if they can make the argument. Yes, we were watching
word war debates. I thought this was called world war debate
for a significant amount of the stream. Was very put off when
I realized it was word war debate,
but we're going Anna Kasparian's currently massively mogging
Pearl. Okay. the the like scoreboard, the HP bars for these two
participants are roughly the perfect inverse of their heights.
Okay. >> Raise the children that the former couple had
together. >> Are are you guys equal or not? You want to
be >> Yes. Equality means that you're both responsible
for raising the children and that includes the cost. >> You
should have equality but not at the expense of men. 50/50 custody.
>> I legitimately just don't understand how the red pill
movement ever took off. It's like it's pretty conservative to
take care of your your former spouse, assuming they didn't cheat
on you and your kids. And realistically, even in the case where
they did cheat on you, you want your kids taken care of. You
don't want your kids going hungry, right? I I just feel like
it's so crazy that people argue, "Oh, well, h how are we going
to be so unfair to men?" It's like, well, if they're the only
provider, they're the only person making money, they have to
take care of their kids. It might have to be mandated. >> Yes.
Equality means that you're both responsible for raising the children,
and that includes the cost. Equality, but not at the expense
of men. 50/50 custody.
5050.
No child support. No alimony. That's >> She was about to
She's about to argue. 50/50 child costs. No child support. What
do you mean no child support? Do you mean no child support, bro?
>> That's equality. You don't >> make sense. If the
woman was a stay at home mother and doesn't have a source of
income, how else would she take care of the kids following a
divorce? >> By getting a job just like the men.
So again, dude, the bread pill arguments are so easy and so dumb.
Uh, she should just get a job. Okay, so she gave up her ability
to go to college at in her normal years to go to college, to
learn a trade, to to learn something, to get like a career. She
gave that up to raise your kids. And now you're like, "Oh, go
get a job, bitch." It's like, "But you just put me for my best
years for learning in stasis, and now you want me to go get a
job? You want me to go work at McDonald's? What the is that about?
You want your kid's mom working like 60 hours a week to have
like the a place they could barely keep together? [__]
you doing? >> So, you're saying that a woman who doesn't
have recent job history is just going to willy-nilly enter the
job force and or work force, I should say, and easily get hired.
>> Do you guys care about So, do you care about the children
or not? Because you're making this about like the oh, the poor
husband, the poor ex-husband who doesn't want to pay the child
support, doesn't want, you know, to take on any of the responsibilities
of having children in the first place. Why is it that you seem
to have a problem with men carrying out their responsibilities,
but when it comes to >> men are dying to care about their
responsibilities? Men are fighting to be a part of their kids'
lives. >> What's the empirical data on that?
>> I don't need
>> Should there be no consequences of
Um, should there be no consequences? I would say if you decide
to have kids, there should be no consequences on the kids. There
should be that's who gets their consequences minimized for the
anybody who doesn't we we both agree on that, right? That's the
first thing and then we move on from there.
Almost all of these requirements, the alimony stuff, the child
support stuff, almost all of this is just downstream of making
sure that your kids are taken care of. And I
>> Yeah, we could have a different conversation about like,
oh, if it's just two two people who don't have any kids, we could
have a different conversation, but I'm still going to have very
similar thoughts there. >> Need data. How many people in
here have had a a family or or or a friend fight for their kid
and not be able to get it? The reason the reason that this happens,
Anna, is because lawyers tell them not to fight because it's
so expensive and they won't win. >> What is that based
on? >> It's based on me. >> You have to provide.
Look, Pearl, I am open to be convinced, but I need more than
anecdotes. I need more than vibes and feelings because we're
talking about something serious here. We're talking about raising
children. We're talking about the shared responsibility of raising
children. That of course includes% of disputed custody goes to
women. That's not equal.
>> 90% That's a totally madeup statistic. Where are you
citing that from? >> All right, let's take a break there
cuz our time actually >> Dude, she just just stare blankly.
>> All right, let's take >> Wow, what a response.
Pearl's got her on the ropes now, guys. Pearl Pearl was laying
She's just lying and wait to spring that trap. She sure got her
now. Is our time actually ran up? >> Uh, somebody asked
like why does Pearl do this stuff? Pearl's channel is entirely
predicated on denying reality. So, she has to go and deny reality.
Um, there are, by the way, denying reality is literally the most
profitable thing you can do right now, which makes it even more
embarrassing that she is so bad at it. Okay. All you have to
do look at Gavin and Sam Trapoli up there just going women are
you be a little funny. Not even very funny. A little funny,
right? You be a little funny.
And it's so easy to deny reality and just do this and she's just
like reading statistics. Uh 40% of these people and then Anna
asks her a question she can't answer. Literally the answer here.
Why don't you just check reality, Anna? Why don't you actually
go in the real world, you stupid ivory tower leftist piece of
[__] Why don't YOU WHY DON'T YOU ACTUALLY experience
life? Why don't you meet people? Why don't you just act like
a normal person? That's literally all you have to do. And everybody
in the audience will go, "Yeah, go in the real world, you stupid
bitch." But she can't even muster like the bare minimum of faking
like she has an opinion. She just had some written down on paper
and shows up and gets embarrassed. I don't get it. >> Those
opening interrogations are over. Let's take a moment here. You
guys want to grab a sip of water?
>> All right,
the next step is going to be >> No, hold on. You You don't
need sound reasoning when you have a cult. That's true. You need
to be able to speak when you have a cult. And Pearl can't do
that. Pearl is like an actual
and I I I can't explain it cuz she's got a good education. She's
got rich parents. She clearly didn't come from like family members.
I have no idea how she's so bad at all of this. No, you guys
keep talking about her maintaining an audience. I don't believe
she maintains an audience. I don't believe she has fans. I don't
believe anybody around her wants anything to do like like nobody
who you even used to watch her content watches anymore.
She is like proof that you can't just bot anybody up that that
not not just anybody could be like an influencer. You can't just
build someone. You need somebody with some amount of charisma.
There needs to be some base level of clay there to mold. You
can't just do it with anybody.
And I'm I'm positive that her original like blowup is entirely
botted, too. And that there was just no sincere like following
for her to keep her going after that stopped. >> 30 minutes.
We're going to open it up again. Open debate. I'd remind you
guys, I know everyone's passionate about this. I get that. But
you can't we can't have multiple people debating at the same
time, right? We got one debater here. We got one debater here.
Let's keep it here. All right. Let's put 30 minutes on the clock
and let's begin the open debate. Bro, I'll let you pick up here.
Go ahead.
What happens to men when they don't pay child support? >> There
are consequences for it, especially when there's a court order
for them to carry out their responsibility and pay child support
so that child can be raised. >> And what happens? >> Do
you think there shouldn't be legal responsibilities
or legal consequences if they fail to carry out a court order
to, you know, take care of their kids? >> I've interviewed
mens that have paid millions of dial dollars in >> Don't
care about your interviews. Anecdotal evidence doesn't matter.
What I need is actual statistic empirical evidence. They should
pay their child
is the average child support payment.
>> a month. >> Like Pearl is not It's not even that
Pearl is like dumb here either. She's also bad at like conversation
debate in general. She's like totally timid about cutting back
in. She's just like, "Oh, don't let me cut you off." Why don't
you call me like really ugly again, Hannah? Hey, don't let me
You just call me ugly. Oh, don't let me cut you off. Don't let
me step on your toes. No, finish your point. No, finish you finish
your point. You finish your point first, Anna. Go ahead. Go ahead.
>> Yeah, that's for someone that makes $24,000 a year.
>> You just told me a woman can just go to work and take
care of the kids totally by herself.
>> How does a guy live when he's paying $500 a month? >> I
Hold on. This would be good, fairy queen, if she if she like
literally said, "How are you out here trying to be the advocate
for divorced men when you have no idea saying all these women
are who like have no idea how the world works when you literally
have a job that's entirely funded by your family? You have a
studio. You have a whole compound that's funded by your parents
that Oh, sorry. I me Hold on.
Sorry. Give me two seconds. I'll be right back. I just got to
I got to run to my door. I'll be right back. >> $4,000
a year.
>> You think $500 a month is too much in child support?
Do you know how much it costs to raise a child? Do you know how
much child care costs, for instance? I mean, that mother has
to go to work, right? Where is the kid going to stay while that
mother is working? How is she going to pay for the the >> What
happens to men when they don't pay child support?
>> She's she's The whole point of that rant is she doesn't
know how the real world world works. She doesn't have like a
real job. She's got nothing. She's got nothing. Okay. She can't
be the advocate. She's useless.
She is the person who's on who's basically on alimony, but it's
from her parents. Oh, I'm allowed to be on alimony. I'm allowed
to be on like welfare, but that's cuz it's from my parents. Shut
>> Sorry. Say that again. What happens to men when they
don't pay child support? >> There are legal repercussions
for not carrying out a court. >> Oh god, >> she's
on the Marco Rubio path. She's about to she's about to b out
to do >> Do you think that fraud should be >> Absolutely.
Okay. So, why is it not illegal for women to fraud men on paternity?
If a man does not find out he's the father over the age of two,
he is on the hook for child support for 18 >> I don't I
don't know.
when it comes to that. But it's wrong. If you're lying about
paternity, that is wrong. And there should be legal >> Why
haven't feminists fought that simple? Then why why aren't feminists
fighting for it, Anna? >> Because feminists fight for women,
>> Right. That's my point. At the expense of men,
>> okay, the answer to this is
who is responsible for that kid. Okay? You need a father. You
need a parent who's on the hook for that kid because the state
ain't gonna take care of that kid. Okay, so here's the question.
If you if you have a kid who's like five, you find out that they're
not your kid. But also, the guy who actually fathered that kid
is either dead or the guy who fathered that kid had no idea that
kid existed. Okay,
who's responsible for that kid?
You think you could just like, oh, well, you get divorced, you
don't pay any alimony, you don't pay any child support, you're
like gone, right? It's like, well, the states you you create
a problem. This unfortunately solves the problem in a way that's
unfair to the men. But it is what it is, man. The state they're
not just going to say, "Oh, we now have a whole bunch of children
that,"
you know, you can't have like a whole bunch of children that
just don't have fathers, don't have parents, don't have people
responsible for them. You can't run the world that way.
>> If he didn't know it was his kid, no. If like basically
he this person once and then you never meet again. and she like
drives across four states after you guys one time and then 10
years later, 5 years later, she comes to you and goes, "Oh, this
is your kid." The state goes, "Oh, she actually lied to her husband.
Her husband's not the father. You're the
>> Do you now from that one that one event, you now owe
child support on that kid? That seems kind of unreasonable, but
>> you guys want to believe women at the expense of men.
Why isn't Amber Heard in >> Because of the Me Too movement.
>> Nobody said that. Okay, watching it back. Nobody said
that. Okay, what's the solution there? Wait, nobody said that.
What's the solution? Watch back just said nobody said that. Wait,
hold on. What's the solution then? Cuz she's saying it's really
up that you'd have to pay child pay child support when that kid
isn't yours. So that's implying that that guy shouldn't have
to do it. Who should have to pay child support? Whose job is
it to take care of that kid? Oh, I maybe watch you back. Maybe
the chat's maybe too lagged. I have no idea. Maybe you're referring
to something else. I thought you were trying to argue that my
thing was wrong. The father. Okay, so the father who didn't know
about this kid has to raise that kid now. I don't think most
guys want to opt into that. But hey,
you had somebody just springs a kid on you, you know, five years
after you didn't know.
If you guys think so, all right, I don't think society be go
would would want to go for that. But
>> you guys want to believe women at the expense of men.
>> No, the state again the the
it's not going to disproportionately fall in the state. the the
risks of your behavior, the penalties for your behavior will
never fall in the state until you're a billionaire. Okay? Then
the risks for your for your behavior, oh Jesus, fall upon the
state. Okay? Then the risks for your behavior do fall upon the
state. But you have to you have to get into the billionaire class
for that to be the case. Okay? Otherwise, the risks for your
behavior and potentially the risks for other people's behavior
fall on you. All right? What about the other guy?
What do you mean what about the other guy? He's the sneaker of
women right now. Oh, wait. She is the sneak of women right now.
Agree or disagree? I don't know, man. I don't even know what
that means. Sorry, I'll back it up here. Oh, not back it up that
much.
Where were we there before I jump forward? We were on the 30
minutes. We're right at the beginning of it. Somewhere around
here. >> Okay. So, why is it not illegal for women to fraud
men on paternity? If a man does not find out he's the father
over the age of two, he is on the hook for child support.
>> It's fine. Give me two seconds.
when it comes to that, but it's wrong. If you're lying about
paternity, that is wrong and there should be legal >> Why
haven't feminists fought that >> Then why why aren't feminists
fighting for it, Anna? >> Because feminists fight for women,
>> Right. That's my point. At the expense of men.
>> You guys want to believe women at the expense of men.
Why isn't Amber Heard in jail? Because of the Me Too movement.
You guys pushed believing all rap victims. And now we have >> Now
they had to pay out a massive
>> You pushed believing all victims. And now we have Wait,
what? Wait, what? >> Now we have rap. >> And now
he had to pay a massive
>> Yeah, but why isn't she in jail? >> You want her
in jail? I
>> Well, the penalties for defamation are what the court's
decision is. >> Wait, was I actually don't know. This is
probably true or else Pearl wouldn't be saying it. Was Johnny
Depp broadly accused of or was he accused of like widespread
abuse? I thought it was like physical abuse and [__]
>> You want people to go to prison for >> He had
to go to two different countries to clear his name. Why isn't
she in jail? He lost millions of dollars. >> To be clear,
you think the penalty for defamation is prison time. >> I
think the penalty for a false accusation is that the woman should
get the same time that he would have gotten if he was found guilty.
Men don't go to prison for defamation.
And see this is the problem with feminists. You want all these
freedom.
>> is Pearl arguing an example that doesn't
accused? Okay, dude. The bed pooping thing that's like enough
to kind of rebalance the scales. Okay, that the bed pooping thing
went public that she had to be like the bed. She is the bed for
the rest of time.
That's that's just so >> But you want to actually be equal.
>> I do want equality. No. If you wanted to be equal, you
would fight for 50/50 child support. No alimony. >> No
alimony. Mhm. So again, if a woman decided to forego working,
decided to stay home to raise the children, and the marriage
doesn't work out, she's got no income whatsoever, she doesn't
deserve any alimony doing that. Number one, that's not even a
comp. Women are not staying home with the kids. And number two,
you have dayare. >> A lot of women do these days, actually.
The tra the traditional women who want to stay home. They want
to be traditional wives and you trash them all the time, which
I don't understand. It seems like women can't do anything right
when it comes to you, right? They're stay at home moms. They're
traditional.
>> I I understand that you can personally attack me. That's
>> I'm not personally attacking you.
>> This Pearl Pearl is like actually you trash stay at
home moms. You even if they like stay at home moms have all the
risk in your world. You're you're with these people. Okay. Personal
attacks are a bit much. It's like no, she's literally talking
about your opinion. Come on, man. >> Okay. These are things
that you have said on the record multiple times. >> But
if you cared about equality, you would care about false accusations.
You would care. I care about false accusations. No, you don't.
>> You don't know me. What? You don't know what I care
about. >> Look. All right. Let's talk about rights that
men do not have. Men do not have the right to be enlisted in
selective service. You know, we have 125k men who were drafted
and buried overseas. Think about that over a second. You talk
about the oppressions of the past, but how >> This is so
This has to be the end for Pearl, right?
This has to This has to be the end for Pearl that all of her
points are like written down. She's just reading a script and
she's just getting mogged repeatedly on every single point. How
could you possibly take this person seriously after this? It
has it has to be over. >> In World War I and World War
II and had no choice. And yet Anna complains about oppression.
Men do not have the right to face their accuser in court when
they have a false allegation and for personal protection orders
that strips constitutional rights away from the man. Women go
before a judge and say they don't feel safe and more than likely
a PP order will be issued. The man was not in court, had no say,
has no defense, and does not get to face his accuser. that is
done on mass and many servicemen and first responders lose their
careers over this because it strips a man's second amendment
rights away based on
this is um so these would be like emergency um like these would
be emergency TTRO's that are literally going to be like put in
place for a week, two weeks, maybe like a month and then you'll
get a hearing to like decide like there there aren't just widespread
um without your lawyer there without your rep without you or
your representation there orders for you to like not go home,
not see your kids, and then there's no trial to follow up on
that, right? They will they'll just do this. They'll say like,
"Oh, we have concern about like danger in the meantime, but here's
when your trial is set." Like that doesn't have the idea that
this just happens one-sidedly and you never get a child to like
discuss it is crazy. That's not how the American system works.
>> No evidence. Men are not the right to raise their children.
Divorce is is no fault, but when it comes to child custody, it's
always the man's fault. He loses his children to the system.
96 hours a month the father does not make. Men have longer prison
sentences. Women get a third of the time for the same crime.
Where are the feminists fighting for equality on that issue?
There have been m there has been rampant discrimination against
better qualified men in hiring across multiple industries. Men
pay more child support and child support orders are not enforced
at the same rates between men and women. Women are more likely
pay not to pay and are not and are prosecuted for non-payment
at lower rates. Men cannot opt out of parenthood.
Men have very few domestic violence. >> Dude, dude, Anna's
like, "Is this real? Is this like is this and are prosecuted
for non-payment at lower rates. Men cannot opt out of parenthood.
Men have very few domestic violence shelters and are not taken
seriously when they're domestic violence victims." I agree with
that. White men in particular are discriminated against when
it comes to hiring and educational attainment. True. The duth
model is a model that law enforcement, courts, and counselors
use automatically that assumes men are the aggressor. The tender
years doctrine is a guideline in divorce used to justify removing
the father from the child's life. The only institutional that
exists is institutional that discriminates against men in favor
of women. Furthermore, US courts do not require receipts to show
how that money is spent by the custodial parent unless there's
overwhelming evidence of starvation, malnutrition, or severe
child abuse. There are numerous reports. You want the government
to check receipts.
>> Let's let her respond to some of that. >> Hold
on. Let's understand something. You want government to be so
big that you literally have the government looking at receipts
to see >> Okay, hold on. Hold on. I do have to give it
up for Anakasparian here. I'll be real. I actually couldn't even
pay attention to what Pearl was saying. She was just droning,
reading totally monotone. I couldn't even bring myself to focus
on what she was saying enough to make a rebuttal. That's that's
incredible work from Anakasparian. Let's give her a round of
applause. That was incredible stuff. I didn't think it was possible
to actually listen to his throne on like that.
She's paying attention. She actually brought up a point in the
middle. That's incredible.
>> that you literally have the government looking at receipts
to see what a mother is spending the money on. >> That's
insane. >> I want no child support and no alimony. >> Yeah,
because you're crazy and you don't live in reality. >> I
want equality. I'm more of a feminist than you, Anna. Cuz I I
say if you want to vote, be in selective service. Be on the front
lines just like the men are. >> Who do you think gives
birth to and raises those soldiers? >> What does it have
to do with anything? Because you assert that women shouldn't
be allowed to vote because they're not all in mandatory military
service. >> I say be equal. You want to vote. Do what the
men do. Men are find out. >> Should women be included in
combat? >> Should women be included in combat? >> Yes.
Do what the men do. >> Do what the men do. >> Yeah.
Fair.
>> Next. Next. Nothing. Okay.
I want to know what your ideal woman is because if you are a
traditional conservative woman who's married, staying at home,
raising kids, you trash that. There's no such thing as a traditional
woman >> there. They cannot they cannot be traditional
in 2025 because women will always have the leverage. >> What
does that mean? What does what does it mean that women will always
have the >> Women have child support to fall back on. Women
have alimony.
>> 10% of divorce >> girl has an easy slam dunk there
with forcing women to do the draft and she didn't go there. Well,
I think that's that is kind of implied by the final point, but
dude, she is it's rough to watch. I can't believe she didn't
go. How did she's like [__] up her own talking points?
Anna's like, "Wait, women should be in combat?" And she's like, "Yes,
women should be in combat."
Like, "No,
that's against your points. Women can't be in com in combat.
Actually, wokeies are trying to put them in combat and lowering
standards and ruining the military. You don't even know your
own side's talking points on this. You out of your mind?" >> Back
on women have alimony. So >> 10% of divorces end with alimony
settlements. 10% >> and they go you just ignore the stats.
They go from men to women. >> They go from men to women.
Billions of dollars every year. >> I thought you said earlier
that women are paying alimony. >> Billions of dollars of
wealth every year is transferred from men to women. >> Through
based on what where are you getting that information from? You
just making it up. >> Okay. We we have it. We're excited.
We can get it to you at the end.
>> We You didn't want to submit Where are your sources?
You didn't want to submit them ahead of time. You did it. The
Census Bureau, Bureau of Labor Statistics. I I cited everything
I
>> Jamie, pull that [__] up. >> Pull
it up, Pearl.
>> The main thing I want people to understand, okay? Pearl's
going to trash women no matter what. That's fine. >> I'm
not trashing, >> but my biggest gripe with you is you're
discouraging
people from entering
>> I don't tell men what to do.
>> Sell me. >> You advise men to avoid marriage.
Dude, >> on marriage. What do men get out of
>> That's sad. It's sad that people think that. It really
is. You get a partner, you get a teammate, you get to build a
life together, and it's beautiful.
>> I feel like
company in this situation.
>> What the [__] >> That wasn't me.
>> Wait, what?
>> I feel like misery loves company in this
>> Oh,
misery. I see
you're a lonely
you're a lonely spinster hag and you just want everybody to be
lonely and miserable like you >> personal attack
>> and how would you know what you get out of marriage
if you haven't experienced marriage in the first place. I'm not
saying that as a personal attack. I >> dude Pearl is like
Pearl looks like she's getting bullied. Pearl is like she's not
responding. She's not saying anything. She's just like sitting
here taking it. hope that meets the love of her life and gets
married. It's not about that, but you trash it without really
understanding what the benefits are. Why do we have phrases like
it's cheaper to keep her? >> Pearl, answer the question.
>> Divorce is expensive.
And by the way, on purpose to discourage people from getting
divorced in the first place. Why do we have phrases like happy
wife, happy life? Because it's true. >> Oh, no. >> Same
with happy husband, happy life. I don't want to come home to
an angry husband. Um, I mean it's a it's a like relic phrase
of like a bygone era where it was just a one one income household
and it's like you can't just ignore what your wife says cuz she's
making work at home. Your life will be if 50% of your household
is upset
which is obviously true. Like even though even though she's not
making the money, she's not making the decisions. If she's unhappy,
you'll be unhappy.
>> But that's not a phrase. >> Do you have any other
like catchphrase or slogan you want to throw at me? What do men
get out of marriage? >> They get a partner that gains 25
lbs in the first 5 years. >> Men get pretty fat, too. I
don't know if you've done a comparative analysis on that. They
actually end up gaining more weight than their wives do.
>> And who cares?
I mean, have a conversation with your partner. Encourage her.
>> That's not true. Most women most men would still [__]
their fat wives. >> How can adults How can men and women
be equal? How can men and women be equal when one is expected
to die for the
>> I don't expect anyone to die for anyone else. I don't
know what that even comes >> Yeah. The men are willing
to die for you every day. The men in the police force, the men
in the military. >> What about the women in the police
>> They're not. They're one, they're 10% and they cause
so many problem. >> Who cares? >> Dude, hold on.
Did you guys see the tweet on this? Give me a second.
Dude, it's like it is a little [__] up how much power
men have on the internet. Okay, where's this tweet? It's about
the Here we go. It's about the the Minnesota shooting. Okay,
when a female cop overreacts and kills someone, it's this is
why women can't be police officers. When a male federal agent
overreacts and shoots someone in the face for fleeing, it's but
he was scared. He's just a little baby. He has trauma. What about
his feelings?
It's like, yeah, no. Uh, dude, man, I'm willing to die for you
every day. This guy literally pulls out his gun. Actual death
cult member. I'm not going to dodge this vehicle. I'm gonna pull
out my gun and make sure I take the driver with me. I'm going
to let myself get run down and I'm going to take the driver with
me. Hopefully. Probably not, though. We all understand that if
that woman was trying to run that guy over, he would have been
dead. He would have been at least he would have been run over
by the car, right? Wouldn't have turned and he never would have
had his gun out in time to actually shoot her. Literally, if
she ran him over, she would be alive right now. Unlucky. What
percentage women make up of the police force? They're in the
police force. My sister-in-law is a cop, actually. >> They
can't They can't do the same jobs. There's videos on the internet
everyone getting their guns taken because they're not strong
enough. >> Are you just making things up?
>> Pearl, what are you doing? Like, seriously.
Next question.
>> Dude, is Pearl okay? Is Pearl okay? >> Do you
realize how good you have it in this country? >> Absolutely.
Best country in the world. And you get the life to live the life
you live at the expense of men. >> No, that's not true.
>> That is true. Show me how.
>> Do you know how many men die every year?
>> Dude, have women been Have women been hiding the secret
of immortality from us? What the Where is this point going? Dude,
she starts laughing at herself.
Bro, what? >> That is true. Show me how.
Do you know how many men die every year?
Just there are men that die every year to get you crab. How many
women die every year during child? >> She's talking about
crab fishermen die every year to get you crab. How many >> to
get you crab?
How many men die every year to get you crab to get you delicious
seafood?
Wait, what? Why did she just say that? What the is she talking
about, dude?
>> Just there are men that die every year to get you crab.
How many women die every year during childirth? Not many.
This country has the highest maternal mortality rate of any developed
country. So, a lot of women do die as a result of pregnancy and
childirth. Yes. >> Wait,
the question should have been just real quick. Do more women
die in childbirth or do men die more men die getting us crab?
By the way, how many Americans die getting you crab? I feel like
the people who do the dangerous who who actually go get crab
out of like the ocean might do something like that. Those are
all like Filipinos, dude. A lot of people in the bayou who they
fall in checking their traps. What the
>> This is painful, man. Do you have any other questions
for me?
All right. Now,
>> all right. Should I move on? Like, what are we doing
now? >> Let me Can I ask a couple questions? >> Absolutely.
Yes. >> Okay, let's just jump in here. Um, so why don't
we do this? I'll ask you one and then I'll ask you one. We'll
kind of go back and forth. >> She probably watched an episode
of Deadliest Catch at the hotel before leaving. I wouldn't I
would not be shocked if that were true. >> I kind of half
jokingly said at the beginning like bro had mentioned I think
you actually said it here too that you believe you may be more
of a feminist. Do you consider yourself to be a feminist? And
how would you define
I don't consider myself to be a feminist mainly because it's
a loaded word and there are certain outcomes from certain waves
of feminism that I don't agree with. Uh particularly
minimizing the importance of men in society. I do think that
there is, you
>> this is what I hear a lot of people say. This used to
be a common thing like I'm a secondwave feminist, right? Like
an argument that third-wave feminists basically made it a zero-
sum game. Like they wanted any gains they could get at the cost
of men potentially. Like that's not it's not a part of it's like
not an equality movement anymore. It's like an uh I'm going to
advance the rights of women or whatever. I that's like what I've
heard. Third. Oh, maybe third. Maybe third. And I'm thinking
of I'm missing up third or fourth. I don't >> Especially
the third wave of feminism that's done that. Um I >> No,
that's that's usually the argument. >> Really value masculine
men and I don't appreciate feminists speaking on behalf of all
women in regard to what women prefer. I think the me too movement
started off as a legitimate grievance with women who were legitimately
abused and it devolved into something laughable and ridiculous
especially when you know someone like Aziz andari gets accused
of being like some sort of sex predator when he clearly wasn't.
So I just don't like how loaded that word is. What I actually
genuinely want is equality among the I'm not looking for women
to have an upper hand over men at all. Uh but we need to be based
in reality and we need to look at the statistics and figure out
what's really going on. If men are getting a raw deal as a result
of divorces, then yeah, the laws need to change. And I genuinely
thought prior to this debate that they were getting the raw end
of the deal, but as I researched this, I realized I was believing
in outdated myths.
So yeah,
>> let me ask you this. Do you believe from and obviously
you are citing a lot of anecdotal stories. I do think it's fair
to point out every anecdotal story is someone's story, right?
So they're not fake stories and they're not meaningless obviously
to the people who live those realities. In a lot of cases are
very painful.
Because of your platform, you speak to a lot of those people.
How much is that informing where you're coming from in this debate?
Is the real stories of people who have been hurt by this >> I
mean, I've interviewed a thousand people. I interviewed a guy
who had his kid transitioned and there was nothing he could do
about it. I interviewed another guy. You spent $300,000
trying to get his THANK GOD SOMEBODY ASKED ME ABOUT my interviews.
Oh my god, I interviewed so many people. Oh my god, you have
no idea. I interviewed a guy who like his kid transitioned. What
a what a coincidence.
>> This guy looks exactly like that guy.
>> Hold on. What is going on here? Elmo, thank you for
the gifted sub. Oh, we have 10 minutes left on the stream and
we need How much do we need here? We need four subs. Four subs
for another hour on the stream. I've not been watching, guys.
You got 10 minutes. Four subs. 10 minutes. Oh my god. >> Kid
back. He actually went overseas to Ukraine during the week. >> There's
actually a lot of stuff I still want to do. So >> kids
life. >> If you guys do one more time, we should >> Impacts
it a lot. >> Yeah. I've interviewed so many men that want
nothing more than to just be a dad and see their kid. They don't
even care about the money. They just want to see their children.
Um and if you ask Anna, it doesn't exist. But if you ask any
>> She didn't say that. She said anecdotes. Literally being
the person who's in your position. And then all you have are
interviews. Obviously, the people who come to you for interviews
are going to fit in a certain box,
>> man. Like they everybody knows somebody that it's happened
to. And commentators can, you know, they can try to minimize
it. They can talk from their ivory towers and pretend it's not
happening. But there's a genocide of millions of men that's going
on in this country. >> You use a genocide. One point >> a
genocide. Let's go,
>> dude. The male genocide.
The ma the male genocide. Okay. Okay. 6 million men
>> Has Kev committed? >> Is this really Is this really
that bad though, Pearl? I've heard that
50% of the people. Okay.
50% of Oh, wait, wait, wait. No. 100% of murders committed by
50% of the population. I'm trying to do men kill people. Okay.
Men beat people up. Men do a lot of crime.
Maybe we need to talk about the MQ. What's the final What's the
final solution for men? Okay,
>> 1970. Similar rates of women also attempt
but fail because they usually don't resort to more violent means
of ending their own lives. >> So, they'll take pills. >> Why
is that? Why is it that every time we bring up men, you have
to bring up >> because we're doing a comparative analysis
here. You can't just throw out statistics without comparing it
to what the rates are among women. >> What I'm pointing
out is I just pointed out that by 2050 more men will have committed
suicide.
And your first response was well women commit suic because it
is a problem that is inflicting both.
>> So this is the first sign of any kind of life from Pearl
where she's it's not she doesn't want a nuance conversation.
This is the first time she's at least signaling in the right
direction. She's at least looking like somebody who could possibly
grift. Very important we acknowledge this and clap. Okay. We
didn't think Pearl was capable. Right? Why do you that that response?
Why is it when I bring up men, you got to talk about women? Oh
my god, that's the first time she said anything interesting.
Is the next story you're covering? Um, I'll probably do Msk talking
to Sneo. That should be pretty funny. I think what what else
did I have here?
I've got a good article on the Minnesota shooting and then like
ICE shootings that have happened in cities. Goes over some of
that stuff. And then
well, I think I think just those two things right now. There's
like possibly apparently Chud and DK debated the Minnesota shooting.
Apparently that was interesting. Maybe I'll check that out at
some point. We'll see. Maybe maybe
>> in this country. It is a tragedy and should be taken
seriously rather than this weird >> but it's war but it's
not going to be taken seriously when you pretend it's not going
on. >> It is going on. Are you kidding me? I mean, how
many of our soldiers, our veterans come back to the United States
after multiple deployments, do not get treatment or help with
PTSD and other mental issues as a result of being deployed multiple
times? Like, that's a real problem. How come you don't talk about
that? You can blame it on
>> Jay, thank you very much for the gifted sub. Appreciate
it. >> Divorce, right? Because those soldiers come home
to an empty house. You think that divorce
>> is the reason for most of these >> men are nine
times more likely to commit suicide after >> How many more
times likely are women to commit after a divorce? >> What
about the women? >> You don't know the number, right? Because
you didn't even care to look into it. >> What about the
women though? That's always what you go to. And that that's kind
of what I'm trying to point out is feminists don't care about
care. >> This is the closest Oh my god. Pearl is trying
to get something done here. Pearl's actually coming close to
cooking. Dangerously close. Just for the people who would be
on the her like cultish side, her like ideological
>> she's almost coming close to not being embarrassing.
He's right there. >> We the liar dude. Thank you for the
gifted sub. Appreciate that. >> They do not care about
equality because whenever you ask them for real equality, pearl,
my point is that is not just a male issue. It is a huge problem
in this country. Women who try to end their own lives are less
successful because again they're less likely to use a gun for
instance or hang themselves. They'll take pills. It'll fail.
It's just a tragic thing all around. But if you actually care
about rates, then you would want to know what's causing the rates
or the attempts at what can we do as a society to help people
to prevent that from happening. And you wouldn't make it specifically
and solely an issue that inflicts one over the other.
>> again, I mean, you're just proving my point because
we talk about male issues, you keep bringing it back to the women.
>> I look, >> I just want you to compare the stats
you're spewing right now with
>> something to compare it to. >> Okay.
Do you think that women should be on the front lines of the military
like the men? >> If they can pass the physical test necessary
to do so, >> do you think women should be in selective
service
>> like the men? >> Yes. Yeah. >> Okay. Okay.
And they should be on the front lines as infantry men >> if
they are physically capable of doing it. Yes. >> Okay.
So, no.
>> So, you want to put people who aren't physically I mean
obese men wouldn't be put on the front lines.
>> Do you think women should be jailed for false accusations?
>> Depends on what the false accusations are. If she's
falsely accusing someone of rap, for instance. Yes. >> Just
Okay. Thank you. I I agree. Do you think that women do you think
that child custody should be 50/50?
>> As long as the court determines that both parents are
capable of being caretakers, yes. In fact, that's the ideal situation.
>> Okay. So, yes. >> All right. Do you believe in
alimony? >> I believe in alimony in specific cases where
the woman decided to forego having a career and working, decided
to stay home and raise the kids. In those cases, I believe she
deserves alimony. Yes. >> But that's a privilege. >> You're
ridiculous. Anyway, next move. >> You said it's >> it's
a privilege for as long as it continues. It's literally It's
not a privilege after it stops.
Dude, if you
Oh, man. It's How do you not understand that?
Like Pearl for example, if Pearl's parents totally cut her off
and she was just put out into the world, she had to totally take
care of herself. All the money from her parents was gone. Anything
she earned by like because she got money from her parents gone.
Does she understand how she would be? Does she have any clue
how much trouble she'd be in if she had to live purely on her
career as an influencer?
Like it's embarrassing for her to talk about it. Well, oh well,
it's a privilege. Yeah, it's a privilege, but now like you set
up your whole life thinking you had this back stop. You you literally
for you you decided to forgo a whole bunch of advantages that
you could have gotten in your in your teen late teens, early
20s, mid20s. You have all these advantages
and then apparently that means nothing and you just you you loser.
You lost. Good one. Shouldn't have trusted this guy. That destroys
the nuclear family. That's like you you hate the nuclear family
if that's your position. >> You said it's ridiculous. >> It's
ridiculous. Especially especially coming from a girl who grew
up in an affluent situation with incredibly wealthy parents.
You don't know anything
>> let's go. Let's go. >> struggling economically
or financially. So to tell a single mother who decided to stay
home and raise her children instead of work that she doesn't
DESERVE A PENNY TO RAISE HER KIDS after a divorce is the most
privileged piece of thing to say. >> This is
this is the type of nagging that drives men to >> But I'm
Dude, wait. What? Good
dude. Anakasparian orarm so hard in this debate. It's crazy.
What the >> privileged piece of thing to say. >> This
is
>> this is this is the type of nagging that drives men
to
but I'm married and you're not. So
>> Jesus Christ. I get it. I get it. >> Dude, Anna
Anna like lets these pauses hang. Why do these pauses go so bad
for Pearl? Is it because she seems so uncomfortable?
The pauses are me for Pearl, but Anna's like not talking. Anna
just seems like she knows she won. She's like Anna is like implying
you're destroyed right now. Are you going to try to recover or
you just going to lay down and leave? And that's every silence
and Pearl just like sits there like being audibly. Okay. The
silence is exactly what that is the whole time.
>> little harder to debate someone who's not an only fans
girl, right?
>> Oh [__] That's kind of [__]
up for all the Only Fans girls though. That's kind of super not
on Anakasparian's like kind of just undercut herself there a
little bit taking out workers at the knees. But
>> never. I don't need to.
>> Not that I'm judging. >> NO, YOU'RE SUPER OH NO.
If Pearl had any whimsy, any wit to her at all, she would have
she would have actually come back at her for that. Anna.
Yeah, Anna, you definitely you definitely were judging 100% right
there. >> It's Why Why isn't paternity fraud
>> Oh, you went back to this. Oh,
dude. Pearl just had an awesome Pearl could have done she could
have cooked with that. Dude, that she could have cooked with
that. Uh, wait. Are you saying you're like smarter than workers?
Are you saying workers are stupid? Are you saying that it wouldn't
be worthy like you you don't think it'd be worth it to argue
with any worker ever? Like she could have totally pressed that.
We've been over this already. It's estimated 6% of men are fathering
children that are not theirs. One believe your stats like American
blood bank association. Are you happy?
>> Onethird of
there should be consequences for that. >> But there aren't.
>> But there are so we agree on that. Next. >> Right.
You can agree but you haven't covered it. And and that's my point
is you guys don't care about equality. You want you want freedom
at the expense of >> Okay. Sure.
>> Okay. Do you think that men should have the right to
opt out of fatherhood since women have the right to opt out of
>> I put a condom on.
>> You don't want to have children, put a condom on >> or
require him to wear a condom. That's >> That that choice
is equally
>> He's the one with the Johnson. He gets to decide what
he does with it.
>> I think I'm more of a feminist than you. >> Sure.
Going great. Congratulations,
>> Pearl's just got nothing. >> This is the longest
30 minutes of my
Okay, I'm going to interject again if I >> Oh my god, every
silence is so painful.
Um, so
one thing that I do think is
Imagine how this feels for Pearl, [__] Imagine how
Pearl feels right now. You think it's long for you? Holy [__]
There is a shift that is taking place in America and I think
you both have alluded to this a little bit. >> Pearl been
up on this stage for a decade at this point. Okay. >> And
so I'll ask Anna first if you would agree with this.
>> Because you said that going into this debate you thought
a lot of these things were true. >> And you started to
see that maybe these things were not as true as you had believed.
Do you believe that your previous belief was informed by nonsense
or the fact that states and legislatores and and courts are changing
what they're doing over the last few years in terms of alimony
and parental time and that kind of thing? >> I think that
with more women participating in the workforce, it's hard to
argue that, you know, women should get paid alimony when they
have their own income. So yeah, I think that the culture has
changed, the workforce has changed, and as a result of that,
the court's weigh whether or not something like alimony makes
sense. And look, much like Pearl, I had heard the horror stories,
and I was basing much of my worldview on situations like this.
>> Wait, I I feel like the only dude, is this just a scout
from like the billionaire incel class? I feel like the only people
who ever get significantly hurt by alimony are like extremely
wealthy people because there's like a there's like a lifestyle
argument, right? That you shouldn't have to go to like a completely
different lifestyle. So, the person could take care of themselves.
They could live like a middle class life with their job maybe.
And I think those are the only people who kind of get like cut
in half or like really divorced are people who have like a a
partner who is making infinitely more than them,
right?
I think that's it. No, you're not even a stay-at-home mom, but
I think sometimes you can get alimony in those cases because
you're like accustomed to the lifestyle.
Bill Gates cheated. Bezos cheated.
Sure. Yeah. Bezos got because
Sorry, Bezos didn't get because from what I've heard, basically
everybody agrees that his wife pushed him to do everything that
made that company go like nuclear. Like he was like, "No, we
should just stick with Bucks. We should just be a Bucks company.
We know WHY WOULD WE GO BEYOND BUCKS? That'd be so stupid." His
wife's like, "No, Jeff. Jeff, shut up, Jeff. We're going to be
like the only marketplace in the world, okay? We're going to
be like the only THE ONLY NO BOOKS. I LIKE BOOKS. WE SHOULD DO
BOOKS."
NO, JEFF. BOOKS. Books are books won't EVEN EXIST, JEFF. BOOKS
WON'T even exist. Okay, get with the times.
You built a whole website. How the do you not understand that
books aren't going to exist, you stupid? >> Based on anecdotes,
basically. And so when you look at the statistics and the broader
picture, you have a clearer idea of what's actually happening
in the aftermath of the >> Kindle is actually what got
them divorced. Okay. He thought he finally cooked. He's like,
I got the boys to make we call this we call this a e in display.
It looks like ink. It's e ink. Okay. And we're going to put the
books on it and it's going to be awesome. And then that part
of the business is nothing. And I'm making this up. That part
of the business totally like flops. It's barely anything. And
like the actual marketplace takes off and he just can't handle
his last failure. Like I'm getting I'm cheating on you, [__]
[__] you. Yeah, e- in displays are actually awesome.
I was sort of doing a thing there. Yeah, e displays are are awesome.
Yes, this is true. >> The divorce.
>> Would you be willing to concede at least that maybe
some of the reasons some of these things are shifting is because
of people like Pearl and others who are drawing attention to
these stories?
if she says possibly just not Pearl
she should just say like maybe for people kind of in the same
area as Pearl but not Pearl. This would convince me that like
all women or all men need to be killed. If I if I listen to Pearl,
all men need to be would be my outcome. Okay, that would be that
would be it. Holy sh >> I think we could all agree that
until recently a lot of those stories were just stories you hear
from other people and it was not allowed in media at all. It
was not discussed. Would you at least concede that? I'm sure
that there are advocates who have fought to maybe change the
way these
>> all men. Yeah. As in Pearl is an advocate for men and
Pearl is so wrong that I might think that men need to be like
eradicated based on listening to her for two seconds. >> There
are advocates who have fought to maybe change the way these court
cases play out. Sure. Uh I don't know about Pearl, though. >> I
understand. We're in the debates. You can't give >> Yeah,
it was too easy. That was low hanging fruit. Okay. That was obvious.
That was pretty obvious. All right, >> Earl, in your experience,
the men that you talked to,
>> do you see a difference in terms of the age of those
men where maybe it's getting better for some? Because I would
take it that some of the guys who were a little older and have
been through this in the past, the courts are starting to recognize
and realize that maybe it's not very fair.
>> Why? And why do you believe that? You think the courts
are completely >> I mean, one of one of I mean, there's
men that write into my show every day just talking about how
much they want to be fathers. So, um, >> let's be real.
50% of the only person writing into Pearl is Henry Resilient.
Okay. Henry Resilient sends her emails all the time. She's the
only one who understands that women are and they take your money.
She's the only one who understands. This is Henry Resilient the
whole time. I GOT GOLD BURIED IN THE BACKYARD. YOU HAVE NO IDEA
HOW HOW BAD THESE women are. I hope it changes, but right now
I would say no. Do you think it's fair that all of the young
women who were prayed upon as minors by Jeffrey Epstein are now
experiencing yet another administration engaging in a coverup?
>> Or was it the female's fault for being prayed upon by
a disgusting?
>> I'm just curious. >> Back to the debate. Apparently
we have apparently we have 30 minutes of Anakasparian asking
pearl questions after this which is just going to be >> system
especially as it pertains as pertains to divorces but we're talking
about a guy who got a sweetheart deal after
minor girls and then even after that multiple administrations
Democrat Republican doesn't matter engaged in a cover up ensuring
that those victims would never get justice >> and this
has to do with with this >> I mean you want to talk about
the unfairness in the court system and how terrible it is for
men. What about how terrible it is for women?
>> Look, that has nothing to do with any >> I think
in fairness, you got to you got to admit that's an anecdote,
too, in comparison to the overall statistics. >> It's a
pretty big anecdote. >> He's a big anecdote, but he's also
an untouchable anecdote, right? He's a little different than
I think it's super >> So, let's let's go back to >> Wait,
what the
uh Don't you think you like shouldn't talk about Epstein? Actually,
shouldn't you just like not talk about Epstein?
Wait, what did this guy do? What did this What this guy I feel
like this guy was on the aisle. >> What the hell? >> We
got 10 seconds, so we won't we won't Hold on. All right, here's
what we're going to do. We're actually going to take a break.
Uh we're going to come off of the stage and then we're going
to actually go up to the analyst and get their take on this first
30 minutes. All right, take it away, Sam. Good job.
All right, we are here back at the Wise Wolf Gold and Silver
uh analyst desk. Boys, girls, everyone, let's start with you.
What do you think, Kyla?
>> Well, um I >> Okay, she's going to I feel like
Kyla's going to try to be nice here, dude. I feel like it might
be tough to truly put into words just how bad Pearl got blown
out there. Like, dude,
is Pearl
actually a human being? Are we sure that she's not like a gibbon
in a wig? Okay, can we get Can we check this?
I believe there are apes that exist in the wild with a higher
reasoning capacity than Pearl Davis. All right, I I know it to
be true. I don't need to see a study. I believe it to be true.
>> I think Anna said it all, you know. Uh I think whatever
opinion you have on the topic, that was an absolute bloodbath.
Uh huge. >> Hold on. What is a gibbon? Gibbon. This is
a gibbon. >> Back to Pearl for coming out. But if you're
going to hold this position, you should be able to support it.
And if you >> that was a blood bath, she says, "Hold on,
I got to start over." >> Well, um I think Anna said it
all. You know, uh I think whatever opinion you have on the topic,
that was an absolute blood bath. Uh huge respect to Pearl for
coming out, but if you're going to hold this position, you should
be able to support it. And if you think that Pearl won that debate,
you're probably like, I that was a blood bath. That was rough.
Well, you know, when you kind of get into it and you watch it,
this is Anna's world and we've seen her on Pierce Morgan and
stuff like that. And, you know, so Pearl stepping up into this.
God bless her. Thank her for doing it. Uh, I do think Pearl had
some wonderful moments there. >> Does Sam does Sam have
a favorite moment for Anna on Piers Morgan? Cuz I do. Does he
have a f I have a favorite moment of Anna Kasparian on Piers
Morgan? >> Uh, I think she's been running a lot of defense,
got in some nice shots, and she got bigger reactions from the
crowd, I thought, than than the other way around. What do you
think, Gavin? Well, I guess I'm because I thought Pearl did great.
I think that >> You think she won? >> Well, you know
what I noticed going on over there? Anna doesn't have kids. Pearl
has a kid. And Anna was doing this like masculine thing where
she was being
>> what? Wait, what?
>> Really, you know, viferous and attacking Pearl. And
Pearl had this sort of like
>> Why does he think Pearl has a kid? Why are we infantilizing
Pearl? She's got 2 million subscribers. When you when a woman
has a kid, >> we are absolutely infantized. >> Pearl
doesn't have
>> Pearl doesn't have kids.
>> If Pearl had kids, she could never have tried to go
and and cozy up to Nick Fentes. Okay. Because of the race of
her kids, obviously. >> I'm saying women who have given
birth, women who given birth are better than women who haven't
given birth. >> Have a child. >> Sorry. You're more
of a valid woman if you have a kid. >> Yeah. I mean, there's
a lot going on >> I I had a miscarriage. So, am I less
valid or more valid as a woman? Well, what happened to you was
obviously >> Sure. But am I more valor less valid as a
woman? >> Well, you're kind of less valid. I still love
you. Okay.
>> That's why you cried when you had a miscarriage because
you of course you cried. I cried. >> You didn't cry at
all. You just were terminated and moved on. >> Yeah. That's
just another day in the >> Another day. >> I was
like, "Oh, >> miscarriages. That's my day. You were >> It's
obviously horrific when a woman can't have a baby. >> But
when a woman like Pearl has this sort of like calmness around
her where she goes, "Oh, really? We're doing this? Okay. All
right. Uh, that's >> about Anna is aping male characteristics.
She's getting super aggressive and attacking like a a weird little
pitbull that's that's mimicking male behavior, >> but it's
also kind of ridiculous to say that we live in a culture where
women don't get treated better than men. I mean, let's be honest
here. I mean, I I have this theory. Men make the rules a >> But
did Anna even argue that?
I don't think Anna argued that. She was arguing basically that
men don't get like a totally raw deal.
There are like trade-offs. It's I'm sorry if if you think like
one gender, one in 2026 gets like a massively raw deal, you're
just wrong. There are trade-offs. There are easier things for
women. There are easier things for guys. It's not I don't know if
it's 50/50, but it's like close enough that it like why are you
complaining? The the problems come from like the the man or the
woman wants to do one of the things like they want to do something
where the other gender other I guess has the advantage and then
they're not quite as successful there. And that feels like really
unfair.
That sucks. Uh it shouldn't it shouldn't be like a limiter >> business.
Women make the rules of society. Okay. And that's why there's
things that women can ask men anything they want in debating.
I mean in dating, right? Uh how much money you make? What kind
of car do you drive? How tall are you? There are things you are
absolutely not allowed to ask women. Uh what's your weight? How
old are you? What's your body count? Which are all things guys
want. So this notion that it's like even Steven is absolutely
ridiculous. The notion that the courts treat men and women equally
is also ridiculous. How many times have we seen like a a man
and a woman commit a crime and the guy gets 30 years and the
chick gets like 2 weeks in prison? It happens all
>> Anna and I wouldn't disagree with any of >> she
say I think Anna and myself would both agree that's wrong when
that happens. Women get infantilized as a result of sex all the
time which is what you guys are trying to do to Pearl right now.
The reality is that if you watch that painful everyone knows
that that was painful and the reality is it sucks for Pearl.
You know, it's tough coming out here and trying to be a debate.
>> Well, she's taking on, let's face it, one of the Michael
Jordans of debating. This is Anna's world. Don't take the debate
and don't profit off of this
Anna was a rabid pitbull.
>> One of the Michael Jordans of debating. Anna's like
not bad in a debate. She clearly like studied up for this and
was she came to like put Pearl in a grave, right? Anakus Barry
came here with like a dull knife and held just pearly things
down and just like scalped her in front of an audience. All right,
that was brutal to watch. That's what that's the only thing an
Kasparian came here for. She's just leaving with just Pearly
Things scalp. Okay,
but the Michael Jordan of debating, you don't call M Michael
Jordan didn't become Michael Jordan by like destroying somebody
with spinal muscular atrophy in a game of 101. Okay, that's not
what happened. It's just some dude laying there like fell out
of his wheelchair. He's like laying there on the ground and Michael
Jordan's just styling on this
11 nothing, you're owned. All right, that's that's not how Michael
Jordan became Michael Jordan. That's what we just watched Anakasparian
do. Okay, it was basically that >> mimicking male behavior.
Pearl was this serene mother who was like, "Oh, is this what
we're doing?" >> Like a small girl. >> Okay, I'm
telling you the facts. Uh, I guess you're not telling me the
facts cuz you and I both being Pearl. You and I both know that
was painful, uncomfortably painful.
>> You got to have a baby. You got to have a baby soon.
The notion that women are committing uh unaliving themselves
anywhere close to the number that men are. And the reason that
maybe Anna was like the reason they didn't do it cuz they're
they're not as violent about. Not true at all. Not true. Men
off themselves at a much higher rate. And I'm sorry, but the
notion of give me statistics like Pearl is like chat GPT is hilarious
to me. >> Here's what I would say. The irony >> Pearl
if you're gonna have somebody else write your notes. Wait, >> the
reason they did anywhere close to they're not as violent about
and the reason that Anna was themselves notion that women are
committing. >> No shot. No shot. Wait wait
close to the number that men are. And the reason that maybe Anna
was like the reason they didn't do it cuz they're they're not
as violent about. Not true at all. Not true. Men off themselves
at >> Why do I feel like Never mind. I got I got the idea.
Sorry. I see him drinking. I literally had the idea that he was
>> much higher rate. And I'm sorry, but the notion of statistics
like Pearl is like chat GPT is hilarious to me. >> Here's
what I would say to Pearl. If you're going to have somebody else
write your notes, tell them where they cited things from so you
can at least not look like a dumbass when you're asked where
it's from. >> Now you're getting aggressive.
Now you sound like a dude. >> So aggressive right now.
>> You're not a dude. Stop being a dude. >> Women.
Stop it. >> Stop saying infantilizing. No one's infantilizing.
I'm putting Pearl on a pedestal
one time. >> It's not her fault she didn't know where her
stats were from. >> We're not talking about that. Who had
Who knows uh what college uh uh survey this came from. It's not
listed. >> You should probably if you put it in your notes.
Yeah.
>> You guys understand that this is going to lead to Queen's,
right? You guys all know that we just knocked over the first
domino on on the way to Queen himself. This is going to get worse
for Sam Trap. Arrodite's going to be like mocking her or mocking
him and eventually
Red Bar is going to go and react to this clip and and like totally
blow up Arodite. Totally be like, "Oh, this woman's awesome.
Let's go watch some of her other content." He's going to watch
that content or something. He's going to find a video. He's going
to talk about how awesome that content is. And eventually, this
all ends with a pistol in Quimman's mouth. Just so you know,
we just watched the first domino get knocked over. It's terrible.
It's It's tough to say. It's tough to see it. Okay. It's It's
rough.
It's It's all falling apart, guys. It's >> Yeah, you should
probably know where you're citing your stats from. >> You
should know all I mean what you >> not all stats. The ones
>> This is classic Marxism, by the way. Classic Marxism,
which is don't believe your eyes, your ears, or the wisdom of
your experiences. So, Anna's painting a picture that it's like,
"Woe is me." Like, like how many more uh women's homeless shelters
are than there are men? There's like it's not even close. and
get more funding in general because compassionate group. Yeah.
But I don't even think Anna would disagree with this. So like
if you want to engage with what Anna and I believe, engage with
what we believe. >> What? Okay. Ex. What have we gotten
wrong in what you believe? >> Okay. So for example, Anna
didn't even begin to try to pretend that the rates between men
and women are equal. She said she 100% said that. >> What
she specifically said is that men do die by more often. But part
of the reason why is because women use less lethal methods, which
is true. >> That is such a crazy >> less legal methods.
That is such a crazy statement that you're saying the reason
they didn't do it was how they did it. You don't know that at
all. You're just going you're just going off a feeling on >> Nope.
There's just data on this. >> There's data. Okay. Give
me the stat. Where's the statistic from? >> I don't have
it off the >> WAIT, I DIDN'T HAVE TO PREPARE for >> Hold
on. Can we get a Can we get a quick Destiny check in? Can we
get a quick Destiny skin lock here? >> I don't have it
at all.
>> I didn't have to prepare for a debate. I prepared for
a debate. I didn't have to prepare for a debate.
>> I didn't You see like the headshake. The headshake.
Okay. The Wait. Oh my god. I didn't have to Oh my god. Are you
serious right now? Oh my god. Oh my god. >> Prepare for
debate
analyst. >> If you don't It's so dude. It's actually so
cringe how often it happens.
>> Don't know where they're from.
>> O, brutal voice crackers. >> I didn't have to
prepare for debate
analyst. If you don't know where they're
Oh, Jesus.
She's just correct here. Yeah, obviously she's correct. Ten.
She's arguing with perhaps two of the least intelligent men above
40 operating the comedy circuit today. Okay. possibly the two
least intelligent people. Yeah, she's correct. She's arguing
with apes. >> Probably the medical bureau of US has these
male suic
I'm life. How many of my male friends have killed himself compared
to my female friends? I'm going to kill myself. I think I'm considering
right >> Dude, Gavin is thinking about offing himself right
now. I might eat a >> Every single person here agrees that
men die by more often. This is of course true. Anna and I both
agree with this, >> right? But you're saying the only reason
it's lopsided is method. >> That's one of the dominant
reasons why it's the dominant reason. >> Women attempt
I think eight times more. >> Oh my god. >> You need
to make a baby. You're going to change totally. Next time we
do this, you're going to you will have had a child and you will
be you will be >> Is dominating. >> Pearl tonight
was serene. >> It feels soed up when people do this. I
have um
like uh my my best friend and his wife I nobody knows me. Nobody
knows nobody even knows I stream so it's fine cuz I I probably
wouldn't tell the story otherwise but like my best friend in
real life his wife had trouble conceiving and it's like something
that like
actually she's had like a super duper hard time getting over.
like not being able to have kids is really these people got married
young and they wanted a family and to like get over that it took
like a pro it was a process. So I don't like Kyla obviously but
but doing this whole thing when you don't know someone's circumstance
it's like
uh it's just really up. It's like one of those things that you
can't really fix. Yeah. It's I don't know. It's super up to to
like bring this up with a woman and then keep like putting in
her face like why don't you do it? Why don't you do it? Why don't
you do it? It does feel like kind of messed up. >> She
was not >> They have something major against adoption.
I just don't think they want to do it. They They got like dogs.
I just don't think they wanted to do adoption. Or maybe they
would at some point. I have no idea. It's not my business. She
was stun locked and >> She was at peace with the world
to bail her debate.
>> But it's like if you're getting name this statistic,
name this statistic and you got to give every single
notes, you know. Dude, are you crazy? >> If you if you
site a stat in your PDF that you prepped for for weeks, by the
way, they had se what, seven pages of PDFs. If you have it pre-repped,
you should probably know where you're citing from. I don't have
to know where the citations are off the top of my dome because
I wasn't prepping for a debate. I was prepping to be an analyst.
But even you and I can agree that yes, men die by more, but part
of the reason, not the only reason, but part of the reason, >> but
not the majority reason, right? I I would say probably the majority
reason that men end up choosing lethality more often is because
there are less offramps for men because by and large the world
doesn't have compassion for men. Nobody gives a [__]
about men and how they feel which is why when they die by nobody
I this is my position
right that's not Anna's position >> I I imagine she would
probably agree with me if she saw this >> you you think
based on what we saw tonight she felt men get more don't get
men deserve more compassion. Is that what you got from that?
>> I Well, no. I
>> um Yeah, I actually got that from her. She was like,
"Oh, I think men get like needlessly
like on for being masculine." Like I she she said some stuff
that was like that.
I I think she had parts in there that I was like, "Oh, she she
does think that." >> Said she would probably agree with
me.
>> But wouldn't that be saying that you think that men
>> I'm not saying she is more compassion by agreeing with
you? That's what she's saying, right? But you're asking me, do
you think that her argument tonight was this? And I'm saying,
I don't think that she made that specific argument. But I imagine
now that I'm positing it, if she can hear me, she's probably
nodding and being like, "Yeah, I think of how the the the whole
discussion on divorce is complete BS." Okay? Is that if you look
at Kentucky, Kentucky
made divorce 50/50, automatically 50/50. And you know what happened
there?
>> You know what happened? Divorce went down 30%. Wait,
what do you mean 50/50? >> They made it so the the father
and the and the mother automatically get 50/50. It's not going
to we're going to decide in court. It's >> Wait,
is it Wait, doesn't that work way more in favor of women than
men? Wait, doesn't that like isn't that wouldn't Pearl like want
to you for pointing this out that this is better? Wait, hold
50/50. Hold on. >> That's not what Pearl's arguing for
at all. 10 stone. Thank you for the five gifted. Appreciate it,
buddy. >> Um, that's not what Pearl's arguing at all. What?
What the What the Huh? >> It's automatically 50/50 in Kentucky
and divorce went down significantly
because women realize that they're not going to be able to game
the system right now. And listen, I'm not saying moms don't get
treated bad or single mothers don't have it hard. I have kids.
Being a single mother is so hard. I totally respect that. This
is
>> You have kids? Wait, you you have kids?
>> Is not an anti-women
rant at all, but this notion that men
don't for the history of divorce have gotten a short end of the
stick is absolutely ridiculous. A mother has to basically have
to be like crazy enough to say she wants to president to lose
custody of her children. They have to be that crazy. A guy has
to walk a perfect rope just to get 50/50. So, I I believe 60%
of marriages end in like the 50/50. Here's what I would actually
challenge to you. I think one of the problems with the modern
day court is that 50/50 means that men get kids like every other
weekend. And I don't actually think that that's 50/50. I think
that's insufficient. But part of why the court presumes this
is because women are assumed to be back home in the kitchen,
which means if you ask mom versus dad where what's your kid's
teacher's name?
>> Yes. They're still doing the custody thing. They're
doing like the every time I see like a relic of the red pill,
I'm just like, "Oh, I feel bad for you. I feel like you totally
lost. You've lost on every factual grounds you've ever attempted
to fight on, I just feel bad for them every single time." Like,
dude, nobody nobody's on your side. You You lost so badly. Um,
they're not even doing it like super sincerely, I don't think.
But Pearl does. I feel bad for Pearl. Most of the dads don't
know because they're busy working all the time because we've
told men that their value to society is fundamentally the income
that they bring in >> cuz that is their value. Again, >> knowing
your teacher's name is gay. >> I think a man's value.
>> That's for losers. >> That's a woman's job. >> You're
acting like that's a bad thing cuz now we're getting into their
Mrs. Hamilton. Who the [__] is she? >> You
think it's bad traditional values are men are providers, women
are are are nurturers. You think that's bad? >> I think
it's exactly what has created the situation where men have to
fight incredibly hard to get custody of their children is this
presumption. Yeah. Why do you think men are killing themselves
at high weight? Why does nobody have any compassion to them?
Because the moment you go from a boy to a man, nobody cares about
your feelings. You better get out there and if you're not working,
we don't want you to care. We don't want compassion. Uh she's
winning. She's basically taking their audiences from them. Their
audiences are a bunch of super jaded old dudes who literally
just want anybody who's remotely attractive to give even a tiny
amount of about them. And that's Aerodite. Okay, she gets to
be their mom now. See you later, Kio. Um, so this is like I will
say shockingly being on a panel with Sam Trapi and Gavin McKinnus
that's going to that's going to hitch her on to like the perfect
demographic for her. Okay. just like it's basically like as even
more depressing than as gold fans. >> All right. It's
>> we don't like empathy. We don't like compliments. We
don't like any of that >> That's a suicidal me. >> We
just work all day. >> You believe that? Oh, yeah. 100%.
>> And then you take our kids away and we >> I I
think that the majority of men check out because there's seems
to be no way out of the situation. >> That's horrible.
That's because we don't That's to my point. That's wrong. Men
are more valuable than just the men. >> Men are valuable
because of the principles because they fight for cars. You guys
ruined cars.
>> All cars look like cough drops cuz of
>> Cars. Women buy all the cars. They look like cough drops.
Whether it's a Lexus, a Jaguar, they all look like cough drops
because you guys don't like right >> The cars used to be
beautiful. Remember the 50s? You watch Men in Black, you're like
Ford Galaxies. All these cars are beautiful and then you guys
took over all the buying power for everything and now cars are
the ugliest most >> boring bet that the number one consumer
is garbage. >> Do you guys think the number one consumer
of vehicle purchases it's men or women? >> It's probably
men. >> Well, who do you tell the guy what to >> Well,
you can say probably if that makes you feel good%
of the purchase. So, it's just a fact. >> Women buy everything.
>> Women tend to be the ones that are going to the grocery
store making purchase. >> Yeah, I know. But I think like
we're probably talking about mommy mobiles and stuff, right?
So I do they probably have some kind of point here where it's
like well women did like the more I don't know rounded shapes.
That's why Vans started getting that shape first and then eventually
transfers over to cars. There's probably something to it. Maybe
it's more like a drunken rant like a noticing thing.
And in terms of noticing on car shapes, I like Sam Hides noticing
way better. >> This for the entire time
that's true. That's why generally >> hope you're happy
you ruined cars. >> Uh I I have nothing. >> You ruined
cars. >> I think safety standards ruined cars >> Exactly.
Yep. That's another that's a >> Did you know actually that
the woman body wasn't introduced into >> that is Hold on.
That is a synonym. Okay. Safety standards. Who wanted safety
standards? Not men. Men are willing to die for an awesome looking
car. Okay. Women lose women. They don't want to die when they
get hit. [__] you. How about How about get good and
don't get hit when you're in a car? How about >> The safety
standards until like last year. So if if this is anyone's problem,
it's men's problem. >> Last year. >> Yeah, last year
they built a stunt d a body double for >> every single
car looks the same cuz you guys are scared about climate change.
>> Who owns the automotive industry? Men. >> They're
selling to women. >> Who buys the cars? Men. >> No.
Women. Women buy all body type. >> Just making up that
makes you feel good. This is not facts. Women buy all the cars.
You are not listing any facts and you're also saying
I feel bad for men but also we should doom men to the exact
what you're saying right now is not reality. It's just your feelings.
The notion that women don't have a huge say in what car is getting
bought is absolutely crazy.
Women buy all the cars. >> I put down the money. I put
down the >> I wonder if these two didn't get totally drunk
the whole time. I wonder if they'd actually be able to argue.
H Jesus. >> But guess what? If a if a father came or a
husband came home with a car that
>> are they like reprogramming Pearl right now. They like
they're off the stage. They like had to reprogram Pearl to make
it so she can actually respond when um and just sit there silently
when Anna's waiting for questions. They're like slowly trying
to reprogram maybe get her >> Wiped in like his life is
miserable. They have >> they're doing around two. Yeah.
>> Happy wife. Happy life. >> Yeah. 100%. >> So
what's like the whole trope of like men buying motorcycles and
[__] Is that because the woman actually wants him
to buy a motorcycle secretly? >> It's because we're in
a midlife crisis and we feel like nobody loves us. >> Yeah.
Well, why is that? Because nobody cares about men because you
want to tell >> Nobody loves us. >> You're right.
And what I want what I want is a world where we look at men and
we say, "You're valuable not because of the money that you make,
but because of the things that you do." >> Yeah. But listen,
you you're not in reality now. >> Can you just apologize
for wrecking the world? You're not in reality. You ruined cars.
You invented divorce. You elected Hold on. You watch these man
on the street videos. The first thing chicks say, "Got to make
six figures. Got to make seven figures." They're never like I
like a guy with a good sense of humor. >> I do those interviews.
You want to know >> pics? Great debate. Great debate. Let's
send it back to Ben. >> Pearl is waiting for fresh and
fit at Jtock. By the way, they restarted two days ago. What do
you mean? Like they came back from their Christmas break. >> That's
the way it should always come back. A little pyro. All right,
here's what we're going to do. We're going to come back. We have
about 15 more minutes of open debate and then we're going to
get into the final statements. So, we'll pick up our open debate.
Pearl, I'll let you begin. >> I legitimately don't know
if I can handle a Pearl final statement.
>> What's your plan when men stop doing the dirty and dangerous
jobs that keep society running? >> If you could hold your
mic. >> Sorry, I'll say it again. >> Can you give
me an example of which jobs you're referring to? >> Logging,
plumbing, crab fishing, oil
>> Bro, there's no way. Hold on.
Hold on. I have to go to AI on this one. Give me a second. New
question. I have to go to Perplexity and ask. Is crab
fishing particularly
I'm guessing it is cuz it actually autofilled a little bit. Dude,
it's actually Oh, it's Alaskan. Oh, in Alaska.
I see. In some peak years, Alaskan crab fisheries have recorded
fatality rates over 300 deaths per 100,000 workers. Dozens of
times higher than the average worker in the US. Wait, why is
it so dangerous? Hold on. I actually want to know cuz what? Dude,
I don't know. She like looked up most dangerous jobs was like
it's crab fisherman and it's like okay but we don't need crab.
Bro hasn't seen deadliest catch. I've not seen deadliest catch
ever. But like I don't know what makes crab scary.
Wait, but why do you have to go into the middle of the ocean
for crab? I've not seen a single episode of deadliest catch.
No, that's what the crabs are. No, you drill into the ice. You
ice fish for the crabs. I've seen people ice fish for crabs in
in Alaska. Yeah, you put traps down. You pull the crabs up. You
get pulled off the boat and pulled to the bottom with by 2,000
lb cages by ropes and ship. Wait, do they have people just like
straight up dying on Deadliest Catch? Do you get to like watch
them get yanked off the boat and dried to the bottom of the ocean?
That'd be pretty cool. Wait, YOU LITERALLY SEE THE GUYS get like
yanked off this boat? No way.
Well, I see why the show gets ratings. That's cool. That's pretty
crazy, man. That's pretty awesome. Okay. I think I've seen like
a part of Deadliest Catch where I saw like that it was in the
middle of the ocean and it was like really rocky seas and I saw
the water coming over. I'm like, "Oh, that looks dangerous."
But I didn't think they went fishing for crab out like that.
I thought you put traps down for crab. No, I knew that's why
it was called deadliest catch. I understood the general idea,
but I thought it was fishing for other kinds of fish out in the
middle of the ocean. I didn't think it was like in the Arctic
in like around Alaska. We need a lot of crabs. Okay. Well, oh
my god.
>> Yeah. Those are dominated by men. They have the the
physical capacity to do it. Men and women are built differently.
>> What's your plan when they stop?
>> I mean, we're going to have a problem.
>> Are are you suggesting that women should be forced to
work on oil rigs and things like that? >> What is your
plan? That's a >> what do men get out of
>> the plan is, hey, if the market demands that those jobs
exist, you're probably going to be compensated a more for those
jobs.
The the economy literally handles this. The economy goes, "Hey,
I've got a job for you over here." It's pretty dangerous. It
also doesn't pay very well. Guess who goes for that?
I'm sorry. That's literally how get employed. Okay, that's that's
it.
Like that's that's literally all that happens there. They get
paid those get paid way more than they could get paid. Anything
else for their for their skill set? Okay.
Are males the real race? Yes. Statistically, yes. Males are the
race. Yes. Like that's just factual. That's facts, man. Now the
equal and opposite reality of that that women won't exist won't
accept especially take and is that while men are the race they're
also the genius race okay so unlucky okay unlucky
god flips a coin rich genius
>> I don't have a plan >> I'm mostly kid I'm mostly
kidding in which men no longer do those jobs
>> but not all kidding I truly that is my sincerely held
belief in enough of a way that I'd fight it with people. >> How do
you do it? I don't know. >> What's your plan when men start
walking away from marriage?
>> What's your plan? >> Uh, I don't actually think
it's IQ, though. I think they're really high IQ women. I do think
it's it's uh I think there's a a genuine genetic predisposition
for risk tolerance that is like marketkedly different in women
versus men. that women just have a significantly at a genetic
level you are built this way lower risk tolerance. That's my
belief
in aggregate far lower risk tolerance on average. Okay.
Men far higher risk tolerance which exam which is why men will
go fish for crab in the middle of Alaska. Yeah. Anyway,
risk tolerance is probably due to the risk of hunting it. Yeah,
it could easily be but I do think that's like the biggest thing.
I think plenty of women are very very intelligent. like they
can learn concepts very easily. But like the reason you don't
get I there's probably another genetic component with video games
like especially first-person shooters. But I do think for first-person
shooters and like a lot of current
a lot of current things I don't know why what it is take end.
I just know it plays out this way. Um women don't do what men
do to try to get good at video games. There's no there aren't
women who go eight hours a day,
seven days a week for five years in their prime like
fighting learning years, right? They'll never do that in the
same way that men will. Only men will like throw their entire
life away to try to be like the best Counter-Strike player. Women
won't do it. Okay? Women are incapable. Women could never
99.99999%
of those men totally
actually totally destroying their lives.
But for that.1%
okay those guys those guys reign
>> oh hold on wait what? Oh it ended the stream ended.
I see. We're right after
>> We're right after the break. All I mean >> the
very microphone you're using was built body double for >> No
way.
>> Women buy all the is life great >> marriage to
work on oil rigs and things like that. >> What is your
plan? >> That's
she was about to say this
pearl for a situation in which men no longer do those jobs. >> Maybe
you do it. I don't know.
>> What's your plan when men start walking away from marriage?
What's your plan? So, do men or women get a raw deal from
>> Because you just said men walking away from marriage.
So, is he culpable for doing that? >> Oh, this is Anna's
superpower right here
>> in comparison to Pearl, right?
>> Anna is capable of listening and maintaining like a
mental model during a conversation.
She has like this
theoretically she has a mind. Okay. She like learns things, integrates
them, and then Pearl just said something. What are you going
to do when men walk away from marriage? Wait, if they're getting
such a raw deal, why wouldn't they be walking away now? Aren't
Aren't they the ones getting like totally Why haven't they walked
away?
>> Do do men or women get a raw deal from marriage?
Because you just said men walking away from marriage. So, is
he culpable for doing that? >> What is your plan when men
walk away from marriage? Is he responsible for walking away from
a marriage? >> Oh, actually, I do think now Anna thinks
she means divorce. Now that I'm listening, now Anna thinks she
means divorce. And I don't think Pearl means >> he she
means Pearl means what happens when by and large men just stop
wanting to get married. >> He just never guilty of anything.
>> My point is you [__] on men. >> I
don't [__] on men. I love men. >> The very
yet the very microphone you're using was built by men. The building
was built by >> We was men, dog. We was men. We built the
pyramids and we was men. Let's go. >> And there's no gratitude
or appreciation. You just tell them they're not doing enough.
Got me. You got me. Yep. So, what's your plan when men start
walking away from
>> Oh, that would be funny. That would be funny. Hey, who
put those who created those men? Who put those men together?
Who put all the the blocks together, [__] That would
be very funny to come back with.
>> What do you mean by walking away from >> When
men stop doing the dangerous jobs, when men stop getting married,
when men stop having kids. >> To be quite honest with you,
if American men decide they no longer want to do those jobs,
very likely our government will import men from countries where
they're willing to do those jobs.
uh based uh calling out the importing of of of labor to to with
the domestic labor market. Okay,
listen. It happened to Canada and Ana Kasparian will not see
it happen to America. Okay, she watched it happen to Canada.
It will never happen in America on Anna
KK Kasparian's watch. Okay. America will remain a white nation
under Anna's watch. That's That's probably how >> What's
your plan when they date American women and then decide to stop
too? >> I'm not worried about that.
>> Of course you're not. >> No, I never had any problem.
>> The future is not going to be great for feminists. You
guys are going to get the >> Dude, it's so crazy that
Anna's married to like an American guy who was like a an proam
baseball player. I like I think he I think he got to like double
A or something. We looked this up at some point. Like an American
guy. She's got like a normal marriage, right? And Pearl's sitting
there who's only dated homeless black men or immigrants.
And she's sitting there like, "Life's going to be rough on you
feminists." It's like, "Bro, I you just I you you literally have
no leg to stand on here. You You have like no leg. you, dude,
you are. And by the way, nothing wrong with dating black dudes
or or immigrants or whatever. The
It's just given your the exact way you reason through things,
the exact problems you describe, you have a very weird outlook
on everything. >> Equality that you're asking for. Men
are not going to protect women in the streets. Men are going
to stop signing up for the infrastructure jobs. The birth rate's
going to keep falling. in the future.
>> This is like I I do believe almost all of the red pill
debaters. The thing that fuels them is a total ignorance of economics.
And I haven't even taken I think I took like the two I think
I took macro and microecon.
But like basic economic principles totally elude them. What are
you going to do about just give up all of these jobs? I don't
know. I might go work in those jobs.
Like if you're going to pay me $800,000 a year to go crab fishing,
you're going to pay me $3 million a year to go crab fishing.
Well, maybe. Or maybe those industries just totally disappear.
I'm not sure. But trust me, it's not going to take 800,000 cuz
there's somebody like me who's going to go like what do they
get paid like 90,000 for like the season or something? It's not
going to take very long before they go like 95,000. Wait, 100,000.
Somebody's going to put their hand up and go, "Oh, I'll take
it. I'll do it for that."
Like like that's
dude,
people are just going to not want to work. I guess they're just
going to be like, "Yeah, this is the only thing I've ever done.
I've only ever worked on I've only ever worked on these uh these
fishing boats. It's the only thing I've ever done, but I'm just
going to quit now. I think I'm going to just go be homeless in
America. >> Stop signing up for the infrastructure jobs.
The birth rate's going to keep falling and the future is going
to be
>> Okay, listen. I think men and women serve important
roles in society.
I think that you have a shallow
>> of what I believe number one, but more importantly what
the dynamic is between men and women in modern society. You're
under this weird impression that the anecdotal evidence that
you cite is indicative of the outcome of all marriages. In reality,
study after study shows that married couples tend to be happier
than single individuals,
>> right? They're happy before the divorce.
>> Divorce is terrible. Divorce means that the marriage
didn't work out. Obviously, they're not going to be happy in
the middle of a divorce. >> Correlation doesn't mean causation.
People marry happy people and date happy people in general. You're
attributing it to marriage, but you're not you're not going to
marry someone that's a like a
>> Okay, you're right, Pearl.
>> You know what's really interesting is if you look
I'm sorry. It's just crazy that Anna's married. Anna's married.
She's got the relationship. She's the one defending marriage.
And Pearl's like, "Feminists are really going to hate it when
they're alone and bitter in the world." And Anna's like, "I'm
not a feminist and I'm not alone or bitter. You're like, you're
you have you literally reap all the consequences that you put
on feminists. You've reaped all of those from lives or sorry,
from life. You your life is all of those things. All the consequences
you're going to attribute that that will make feminists miserable.
You have all of those things already. How in the are you talking
to me about this? >> At marriage rates, which have dropped
in the United States, not just in the United States, actually
globally. You'll notice that the people who are less likely to
get married happen to be those who are from a lower socioeconomic
>> Brian, marriage is disappearing from the middle class.
That's true. >> From from poor individuals. Yes.
>> What's do you wonder why?
>> Cuz women marry rich. People forgo >> Hannah's
trying to get some some economic populism in here. Okay. trying
to do her economic populace talking points like women are like
money hungry gold digging. Yeah. Okay.
>> Due to their own personal financial
>> So women marry for money a lot.
>> Okay. So I'm going back to this. >> Let me ask
you something, Pearl. >> Would you be willing to marry
a guy who's poor?
>> Cuz I married a guy who was in debt and love the hell
out of him. Best thing in my life. >> Would you marry a
guy who is broke, no career, and in debt? >> That's very
That's very nice, Anna. >> Would you? >> So, I'm
going back to >> answer the question. Would you marry a
broke guy in debt? >> All right. So, we're going back to
>> um your your anecdote is cringe and gay. My anecdotes
I'm going to talk about this guy who like got cut in half by
his wife again. He's a vet. I'm going to do that actually. >> Would
you? >> Would you? >> All right. This is the nagging.
This is the nagging again. Okay. So, >> I'm pushing you
to answer a question because you are judging women making a blanket
statement of who they would be willing to marry, who they wouldn't
be willing to marry, but you're not answering the question yourself.
Would you be willing to marry a broke guy in >> Does your
husband have to listen to Does he have to listen to >> Oh,
he loves it. >> All right. Can I go back to the >> That
Why do you don't want to answer >> Yeah, why not? >> Just
say love is love is love. Now, back to the question. I actually
wish Anna would start going deeper and just being like, "Do you
notice how you like can't actually like engage in a conversation?"
You know, there's like everybody can see things that you're missing
right now. They can see how you can't put together an argument.
They can see how you can't integrate anything I say and respond.
They can see how you are just reading from a paper because you
don't have any thoughts of your own. Do does it concern you that
everyone else sees this and you can't see it? Like, doesn't that
make you feel
sort of like a freak? like you're up here, you've got nothing.
You You have no idea what's going on. You understand? This is
We're just all laughing at you. Everyone here is laughing at
you. You are a loser. We can all see what a loser you are. I
don't know if you've diluted yourself into thinking that people
can't see it. I I know there's a nagging voice in the back of
your head that lets you know that you're a loser, that hey, everybody
is laughing at you. I want you to know that voice is correct.
That voice has always been correct. Okay? It's never not been
correct. You need to start listening to that voice. It will provide
you the shame you need to possibly make something of yourself.
I like something along these are the this is what you need to
start saying to her because holy yes, she has the polar opposite
of whatever imposter syndrome is. Yes, it's like the exact opposite
of it. Okay, >> men 88% of the of the food the power. >> No,
no. Some people have imposter syndrome matrix user and they get
this feeling that there's like a voice in the back of their head
that says they've got something unearned. She has that voice
and she's been ignoring it. For her is real. She is an imposttor.
She is actually not a person. >> Grid 93% men. Transportation
95% men. Communications 90% men. Material production 78% men.
Software 80% men. Auto workers
98% men. Carpenters 98% men. Electricians 98.
>> Wait, what fields are these people going to go into?
You telling me every carpenter is going to stop and they're going to
go be nurses or something? You're going to take all the disproportionately
male jobs and have everybody quit them? Yeah, those fields are
going to like grind to a halt, but also where are those people
going to go work? Are you going to go be like a nurse? You're
going to go to nursing school?
Guess what? A lot of the a lot of the careers and this is the
unfortunate truth. A lot of the careers where women do dominate
are because you need like a level of empathy to want to help
and like give up some economic freedom of your own, some economic
success of your own to be in them. You're going to go and get
paid way less to deal with way more problems and work way harder
as a teacher. Okay, I guess. Okay. Yeah, I believe that you're
going to go you're and nursing is one of the ones where like
I'm not sure if the the trade-off might be about correct. You
know what I'm saying?
The trade-off might be correct for nursing, but it's like, dude,
nursing is gross. Nursing's gross and the hours are long. They
do get paid a lot of money, but I I do think that's another one
where it's mostly dominated by women because women do they are
more compassionate. Although, I will say every nurse that I know
that goes beyond past 5 years, it's because they're not compassionate,
but because they've like kind of been black by society. But hey,
that's just
that's just me. I don't know if you guys know this. You guys
know that? You guys know a lot of nurses. I happen to have like
a lot of family and friends who are nurses and I'm just like
they actually all become psychopaths in the end. Okay.
A little bit. They have to. You get way too black doing that
job. You like have to be a bit of a psychopath to be a nurse.
No, they get into it.
They they get into it as compassionate. That's how they get start
trading. And then and then stuff takes a dark turn once they
have to start dealing with reality. It's rough. Okay. >> 8%
men. If you remove the top maledominated jobs from the economy,
you would have no running cars, no housing, no electricity, no
open machinery, materials
or fabrics, and no computers. There would be no buildings and
no Amazon delivery. >> I've never once said that are not
a very important feminist of American society. >> You want
men enslaved to women for nothing in return. >> No, you're
just making >> That's what you want. That's what you want.
You want men on the hook. WHAT HAVE I SAID THAT gives you that
impression?
What have I said that gives you that impression? >> You
want men on the hook for child support. You want men on the hook
for >> You want men to not take responsibility for their
own. You've been on the air for 20 years and you have not advocated
for men that are victims of paternal. the the shot for all of
these arguments for the whole like men get and all of this is
just like wait you're supposed to be advocating for like tradition
the traditional family the nuclear family the family unit right
you're supposed to be arguing for all these things and you only
advocate for things that destroy it
like that's why you're a grifter that's why this whole thing
has been debunked it's like over completely over black pilling
hoods just eat up straw mans I I truly don't believe that it's
this bad this is giving you the false this is a false reality
right Now, Pearl doesn't have viewership. Pearl doesn't have
viewers. Pearl doesn't make money. She's like completely destroyed
in terms of her reputation online. This probably doesn't even
cut into whatever she does that much. Like, the only people who
still sub to Pearl, who still watch her content with any frequency
are weird fetishists, okay? People who like tall women who humiliate
themselves. There's just like a weird niche fetish group who
have retain who she's retained. And those people love this content,
okay? They love it. maternity fraud. You want men to do all of
the work, get no credit for nothing. And men aren't going to
do it anymore. They're going to walk away,
>> They're not going to do it anymore.
And feminists, as you said, have no plan for when that happens.
And I wish >> What do you want their plan to be? You think
it's a feminist responsibility to plan for this madeup society
where all men decide they no longer want to work? >> You
know what's funny? She actually advocated for left-wing polic.
>> Dude, have you
seen how cool video games are now? Men are always going to work.
What do you mean? I'm not going to play I actually don't play
video games, so me. I bought, by the way, over the Christmas
break, I bought Cyberpunk. I installed it and then I never played
it. So, I bought Cyberpunk 2077 and I've never played it before.
I probably should play it. I've heard that it's
I bought it and then I'm like, "Oh, I just don't I'll play Civ
7 again." I don't, dude. I don't know. I guess I'll I'll play
Civ 7 again. It uh Cyberpunk is boring until you get to Johnny
Silverhands. Silver hands. That's uh Kiana Reeves, right?
You might just be 30.
Um like I understand what you're saying there that I I don't
but no, I don't I think a lot of people who are like 30 and 40
like video games. Anyone who grew up with video games loves video
That's That's not what that is. And it's not like I don't do
other stuff. I'll like read or just do content. It's just for
me like video games. Well, I guess other than Civ. I do play
Civ a decent amount unfortunately.
But that's I don't spend very much money on games. Build Tech
Tree first. Okay. All right. >> Policies last 20 years.
And then she got assaulted by a homeless person. >> What
does that have to do with the topic? because it was the
Pearl pulling out the you literally got strategy. Let's see how
this plays out. Uh, you were by a homeless person. Did you know
that you're molest you're by a homeless person?
>> Made up society where all men decide they no longer
want. >> Hold on. The last the last minute Hail Mary. What
am I going to do when men walk away from us in this madeup society?
Pearl. Um, you were raped. You got you almost got raped by a
homeless person or >> Yes. You know what's funny? She actually
advocated for left-wing policies last 20 years and then she got
assaulted by a homeless person. >> What does that have
to do with the >> Because it was the result of what you
voted for, Anna. >> Dude,
oh, why did you say yeah, dude? What? Oh, that's that's like
such a crazy thing to pull out, but Anna just went, "Yeah." Oh
boy. I that was a weird time to pause. You voted for your own
>> 20 years and then she got assaulted by a homeless person.
>> What does that have to do with the >> Because
it was the result of what you voted for. Anna.
>> I first of all and so
>> you went voting.
>> Bruce Willis, thank you for the gifted sub to phobia
one. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. >> Want to know why?
Because >> you think I voted Hold on. You think I voted
for homeless people to go around sexually assaulting people >> because
Anna was >> by the way I got assaulted by a guy that was
crazy. Was that something that he did or was that my fault too?
>> All right. So the other crazy >> well if you dress
like that >> is that Anna complains that women's
>> is what Pearl should have said not my opinion what Pearl
should have said >> seriously while a whole event was catered
around her opinion.
The other thing that's crazy, what are you talking >> Is
Anna complains about women being oppressed
and yet she had less experience than her co-host at the Young
>> Hold on. Hold on. What were my complaints about women
being oppressed? Can you be specific?
>> What did I say? Go ahead.
>> Go ahead and quote me because you make
>> and you just think like it's going to stand. You've
never had a strong woman
>> assertions. So, go ahead and tell me what what have
I complained about. >> Give me the quote. >> The
nagging. You said women's opinions are not taken seriously.
When did I say >> And she's explicitly dismissing Anna's
concerns and saying that it's nagging.
She just did that while she's explicitly going and listening
to Anna make criticisms. Hey, you're not even quoting me. You're
just making [__] up about me. And she's like the
nagging. >> The nagging. You said women's opinions are
not taken seriously.
>> when did I say that?
>> I'm about to I'm about to amaranth out
>> in a YouTube video. >> There's two women on stage
right now. A headlined event. >> Oh my god. Are we going
to end?
>> When have I said women's opinions don't get taken seriously?
>> The roundabout. This is like eternal nagging. What is
your plan for when the 80% of women who work in the healthcare
industry no longer >> This is why you should just start
talk. You should actually Oh, you don't want me to nag? I'll
go back to criticizing your clothes, your makeup, your look,
everything about you.
Do you think Do you think your outward appearance is actually
affecting your soul because you're a terrible person?
Okay. And look at you up there. Look at the comparison of the
two of us. You're you're younger than me, Pearl. Pearl, you're
younger than me. How do you look like this? What is going I feel
like there's just some you just got to pull some evil [__]
out. Okay. >> Or want to do it. What's your plan? >> Yeah.
What's your plan? >> Let's give the jobs to the men. They'll
do it better.
>> Because we see what's happening in the media. You know,
women fly planes, they crash them.
women women almost burn down California. You know, people are
dying because they want to make women feel better.
people. Literally, I'm >> What I'm curious about is whether
or not the Pick Me Act ever resorted into anything positive for
you.
>> Are you done? >> I'm not. >> All right.
So, I'm not either. >> Okay. Keep going. >> Now,
the And the other thing is >> I And you guys aren't going
to like this. I do think Pearl actually rattled her slightly
bringing up the the
Okay, I do think Anna's like actually angry now and Anna's like
not responding totally coherently, but she's still winning cuz
Pearl's kind of been a the whole time. Dude,
>> women fly planes, they crash them. Women aren't CEOs
that most female the stats on that. You know, again, I I think
Anna should just say like, if you're going to start making things
up, I'm just going to start mocking your appearance. I'm just
going to start mocking you. I'm going to mock the fact that despite
hanging out with white supremacists, you can only exclusively
date black guys because nobody else will tolerate a woman this
ugly and this massive.
Like I I feel like I would it would be no holds barred at this
point, but Anna is a better person. >> Want stats that
say water is wet. The >> Yeah. I want empirical evidence
>> to back up your arguments >> because you know
you want you want to be in control of telling people what to
think and how to feel. >> No, I want to be in reality.
>> I want to live >> what the I've started getting
to the point where it's really funny to like embarrass people
on the things they claim to believe when they're like obvious
hypocrites. So I'm sorry when I'm when I'm talking about people
who like will wink at white supremacist talking points because
they know that there's like an audience there that they can like
signal to. I'm gonna start laughing at how they're just making
like a a gay libertarian king of America. Okay, you want to make
this gay libertarian Peter Teal this
Okay, you want to make him the first trillionaire in American
history. That's the only thing you're working on right now. All
that's what you That's your That's your return to tradition.
That's your return to tradition. You're going to make a gay like
a gay doomsday cultist the king of America. That's what you want
to do. That's a return. That's going to be like like the like
Augustian Rome. Okay. That we're going to return the Augustian
period of Rome by making this random gay dude a trillionaire.
Very cool.
Don't use a porative. Well, again, it's like operating from their
frame. Obviously, I don't I have no problem with
most of the time.
A couple particular ones are kind of annoying, but other than
that, >> fact-based reality that requires empirical evidence,
not your assertions.
300, we all saw that plane crash on the East Coast. No one's
making that up. >> you do better when you're reading off
your papers, so I'll give you some time to do that.
>> Why? Why does she think the response to having talk
to you is to laugh and say >> in the future? because I'm
sure you'll find yourself in more of these debates. >> I
I actually think that you could be an incredible debater, >> but
you need to look at the broader picture, not just rely on anecdotes
and don't make things up out of full cloth.
>> Feminism empowered women. I'll take the tip. Thank you.
Feminism empowered women to sign up for previously maledominated
careers that they quit. 48 to 73% of female lawyers depending
on the type of firm quit either as junior associates are at mid-career.
One quarter of them site workload burnout mental health. 73%
of women who got engineering degrees in the past 15 years
>> I don't either have
um I I would say
that goes back to the previous thing.
I I do think there's some propensity for men to just go, I'm
gonna men will go, this situation seemed kind of bad. I'm pretty
depressed. I could only grind through this for like another 30
years. 30 years is my max for grinding through this depressing
situation with while changing nothing. Okay, women are just And
that works out well sometimes and works out badly sometimes.
Sometimes you grind through a bad situation, you get you get
yourself through it a little bit, you end up making like a ton
of money, you're really happy, and sometimes you put a pistol
in your mouth at 40. Okay. So, one of two things. I just think
men are more have a higher propensity to do that, right? Yeah.
Exactly. You just sometimes you you bear down. I can only listen
this situation. I want to kill myself in this situation. I can
only stomach this for another 15 years or so. We'll see. Maybe
I'll check in. Maybe I'll reevaluate in 10 years of wanting to
kill myself, but I think, you know, I can make it 15. I >> never
entered the field professionally or quit early mid-career. 55%
of all female accountants quit before or at their midlevel career.
The attrition rate for women in STEM is approximately 50%, these
c companies often bend over backwards to get women hired to the
point of discrimination against male qualified candidates. Then
women quit because they don't want to work the long hours or
deal with the levels of stress for an extended period of time.
With women being 2.5 more likely to take anti-depressants than
men. The money and prestige isn't work worth it to them. They
prefer lower pay, lower workload, and higher job security. Feminism
has empowered women to go to college and take out loans they
can't afford for career paths that will not generate them income
to pay off those loans. The top,
>> right? Because because women
>> men have what? >> Men have higher politics than
women.
>> Oh, debt. She said date and I was confused. She must
have meant debt. >> Right. Because >> because women
put their biggest expenses on their husband's credit card,
>> cuz most male debt is racked up by women >> and
they look and and
women are%
Women are 85% of consumer spending. We lead when it comes to
luxury brands. Men have more mortgage debt, car loan debt, personal
credit card debt, >> right? Because
they're expected to provide. Women make 80% of consumer buying
decision. Again, if feminists really cared about equality, they
would provide for the men. >> Women do make most consumer
purchasing decisions, but I think that's old data, right? I would
wonder how that's starting to change. I would imagine that's
starting to normalize again and come back towards men. I would
still imagine it's mostly women. like it's still probably a majority
women, but that's got to be if marriage rates are dropping, you
know, family rates are dropping, like the the amount of kids
being born are dropping. You would imagine that means fewer like
partnerships, too, and less of like women dominating all consumer
spending. Also, women entering the workforce on mass, you would
imagine after a while that starts to become the norm, and you
get way less of like women making the decisions for men.
Although like dude, I can just say anytime I'm in a relationship,
it's like
we we'll buy stuff, but it's like stuff we need to buy. Like
I just don't care. I'll live like I think I told you guys this
when I first moved into like um the place I was in before this
one. I lived there for a couple years. I literally spent like
6 months just having like a folding chair in my not six months,
like two months with just like a folding chair in my living room.
It was like I was living on my own and I just didn't give a [__]
And I I had like furniture I was like planning to pick up from
um
my my dad has a cabin and he bought new furniture for his place.
He had a bunch of furniture sitting in his garage and it was
like end of fall and I didn't make it up there to pick up the
stuff and I'm like, "Okay, I'll just wait. I'll wait until I
actually have to go." Right. Yeah. So I dude and then then I
got it. But like I spent two months with nothing. I'm totally
fine having like nothing.
No, I have like bedroom furniture though. I don't have like my
my bed doesn't just sit on the floor or some [__]
I have like bedroom furniture and [__] But I think
that's like so women can be in charge of consumer purchases,
but I think they'll just take up buying stuff for the house.
>> They would
>> Sorry, can you repeat? >> If feminists cared about
equality, they would provide for the men. But yet, that is a
small minority of women.
>> Wait, so let me get this straight. Honestly, your whole
shtick is
women should bend over backwards
and do everything they can for men.
>> My argument >> I want I want I'm an egalitarianist.
>> Hold on. My argument is that men and women are both
tremendously important to a functioning society.
They should both be treated with respect. They both serve different
jobs, different roles and in order for society to work, we have
to respect that you say you put the onus and responsibility of
everything onto women while providing cover for the bad behavior
of men. >> Women Women are not equally important because
they don't do the equal men are equally important
that they Women are not equally important because they don't
do the equal amount of work. Men have invented the majority of
the inventions. Men have started Fortune 500 companies. Men do
the majority of the infrastructure job. Men produce 90% of the
>> scrubbing the toilet% of the food >> Um, hold
on.
Hold on.
Very, very important qualifier to add to this. White men >> 90%
of the world's stuff. Who's changing the diapers?
>> Not women. Who's not having kids?
Women aren't having kids. Women aren't doing it. >> Daycare
workers now to be honest. It's not the moms.
>> Not everyone grew up in an affluent household like you.
They need a dual income household in order to make ends meet
in this economy. >> That's not true. By the way, just so
you know, that's not true.
>> You talk Anna, you talk for a living. It's kind of rich
for you to come at me.
>> What do you do for a living? I also talk, but I can
acknowledge it's not that hard of a job.
Well, you pretend it's more important.
>> What do you do for a living >> then? It is, right?
Okay. >> I don't understand, dude. H
gross.
Um I I also don't think I'm important. It's like, dude, okay,
off then. Ah, it's so so gay. It's so gay.
>> Do the majority of the infrastructure job. Men are the
equal men are equally important. Women are not% that they >> Women
are not equally
>> I just clicked the thing and moved it way too >> important
because 90% of the world's
>> who's changing the diapers.
>> Not women raising kids.
Women aren't having kids. Women aren't doing it. >> Daycare
workers now to be honest. It's not the moms.
>> Not everyone grew up in an >> except Minnesota.
Except Minnesota. There nobody's doing it. fluent household like
you. They need a dual income household in order to make ends
meet in this economy. Live reality for
>> Anna, you talk for a living. It's kind of rich for you
to come at me. >> What? Oh, I didn't even realize, dude.
Anna didn't go hard enough here. At least Anna At least Anna
earns her money. At least Anna isn't getting subsidized by her
parents. At least she's good enough at talking for a living to
actually have it as a job where if her parents weren't taking
care of all of her bills, she would still be getting done. Okay.
Her parents don't help her. Her parents have never helped her.
Pearl, can you say the same? >> What do you do for a living?
>> I also talk, but I can acknowledge it's not that hard
of a job.
>> Well, you pretend it's more important than it is. >> Right.
Okay.
>> Well, since there were only about 30 seconds left, we'll
just call it there. All right. Good job. Give these debers